Laissez-moi vous expliquer quelque chose.
j'ai écrit sur
quelques centaines de chansons.
Je les ai tous écrits.
Je vais te donner un exemple, mec.
Je vais essayer de m'en tenir à une chanson...
ça te rapportera de l'argent.
Voyons.
La mythologie de
Charlie Manson en est venu à signifier
avant tout un meurtre vicieux,
mais ces actes terribles étaient
jamais ce qu'il visait.
La véritable histoire de
Charlie Manson... c'est de la musique.
je ne pense pas
Charlie aurait pu être Charlie
sans la musique.
C'était un poète
et il croyait en sa musique.
La musique était le véhicule.
Il voulait vraiment
répandre sa philosophie.
Pour moi, cela semblait être le plus
ordre du jour important et primordial.
En 1968, chef de secte
et auteur-compositeur-interprète
Charles Manson
a accédé au niveau supérieur
du monde musical de Los Angeles.
Seulement un an plus tard
il était accusé d'être
l'homme le plus dangereux vivant.
Ce n'est peut-être pas
aussi évident pour certaines personnes
comment impliqué et enraciné
dans le monde de la musique
Charles Manson semblait l'être.
Terry Melcher produit
Les Byrds,
Les garçons de la plage,
Brian Wilson.
Ce sont deux
énormes producteurs de disques
et ils regardent
à vous, Charles Manson.
Cela ne pourrait jamais
se sont produits avant ou après.
C'était vraiment une tempête parfaite,
cette période de temps.
Quand quelqu'un comme Charlie
pourrait entrer dans la scène.
Il n'y avait pas de plafond, pas de limite,
il n'y avait pas de règles.
Ce film raconte l'histoire
du rêve musical de Manson
et comment tout s'est effondré...
L'histoire de Charles Manson
est l'histoire du rejet
et s'effondrer.
C'était une désintégration
des rêves de Manson
et cela a permis
la folie de monter.
Los Angeles. 9 août 1969.
Au bout d'un
des décennies les plus tumultueuses
dans l'histoire américaine,
les habitants de la ville se réveillent
aux nouvelles
d'un homicide multiple brutal
en plein cœur de Tinseltown.
Dans une scène de crime que la police dit
ressemblait
un meurtre de masse rituel,
cinq personnes dont
l'actrice Sharon Tate
ont été retrouvés tués à la maison
de Mme Tate et de son mari,
réalisateur Roman Polanski.
Mme Tate qui était
enceinte de huit mois
et les autres victimes étaient
découvert mort ce matin
au domaine Hilltop
à Benoît Canyon.
La plupart ont souffert
plusieurs coups de couteau,
alors que l'un avait été abattu
à courte portée.
Les meurtres à Los Angeles sont
une formalité regrettable.
Ils arrivent -
en Californie, en Amérique,
surtout là où la criminalité armée
et la criminalité au couteau est répandue.
C'était hors de cette ligue.
C'était l'horreur de la Premier League.
Nous parlons
à propos de l'abattage
de 8 mois et demi
femme enceinte
et les meurtres
des personnes présentes
avec tant de violence
leur a infligé
qui est apparu
n'avoir aucune limite.
C'était autre chose.
C'était absolument choquant.
Le fait qu'une des victimes
était une star d'Hollywood,
et la femme
d'un réalisateur célèbre,
vu l'histoire
fait la une des journaux du monde entier.
Le lendemain, deux autres
des meurtres ont été découverts
à moins de 15 km,
encore les cibles
d'une invasion de domicile sauvage,
et cette deuxième attaque
envoyé de nouvelles ondes de choc
à travers la communauté locale.
Depuis le début,
les histoires échapperaient
à la sauvagerie,
la brutalité de ce qui a été fait
et certains faits ont
dans le journal.
Dans quelques jours
vous ne pouviez pas acheter une arme à feu
à Los Angeles plus.
Les magasins,
les étagères étaient nues.
Chiens de garde vendus
pour 100 $ avant les meurtres
allaient pour
jusqu'à 2 000 $.
Cela prendrait des mois
pour la police
pour appréhender les coupables.
Et quand les arrestations
ont finalement été signalés,
le monde était abasourdi.
Charles Manson,
le chef d'une commune hippie,
et un certain nombre de ses
adeptes féminins, ont été accusés
avec certains des plus violents
meurtres dans l'histoire américaine.
Seulement deux ans à l'avance,
La Californie avait été
l'épicentre
de l'été de l'amour,
où l'épanouissement
contre-culture
la paix célébrée
et la compréhension.
Mais cette jeune génération
a toujours été regardé
avec scepticisme
par les Américains conservateurs,
et dans le temps au fur et à mesure du mouvement
est devenu plus radical
c'est devenu aussi
plus menaçant.
A travers Manson et son groupe
d'enfants-fleurs meurtriers,
cette menace potentielle
était désormais devenu une réalité.
L'américain moyen
regarder la couverture
de l'affaire Manson,
Je n'ai ressenti aucune identification
avec Sharon Tate
ou ces autres familles
à Hollywood.
Ce qu'ils ressentaient était
ces enfants sont hors de contrôle.
Ils l'ont vécu
aussi indiscernable
des rébellions de campus
et les émeutes de Chicago
et des protestations.
Du point de vue de
la soi-disant majorité silencieuse,
c'était un sens
de ces enfants gâtés.
Tout ce qu'ils veulent faire
est-ce que cette populace s'agite
et prendre de la drogue
et avoir des relations sexuelles.
Et puis tu regroupes
tout ça
dans la pire version possible
de celui-ci
et il y a les meurtres de Manson.
Mais le cas
était aussi déconcertant
et les motifs de
les meurtres sont restés flous.
Bien que la presse
ont été rapides
pour courir des histoires de drogue
orgies et rituels sataniques,
en tant que procureur de district
et la police a sondé
plus loin dans les témoignages
des personnes concernées,
une histoire complexe a émergé.
Manson n'était pas simplement
le chef de secte isolé
ni les sang-froid
criminel de carrière
que son profil suggérait.
Il était également auteur-compositeur-interprète
avec des connexions
tout en haut
de la scène musicale de LA.
Vers début décembre 1969,
les premières histoires ont commencé
apparaître
à Los Angeles
journaux,
que Manson peut avoir
commis ce crime
comme essayant de tuer ou
se venger de Terry Melcher,
qui est le fils
de l'actrice Doris Day.
A la jeune Amérique,
Terry Melcher
était un nom célèbre
à cause de son travail
avec The Byrds, avec Paul Revere
et les Raiders.
Vers l'Amérique centrale
il était le fils
de la chérie de l'Amérique.
Mais comme l'enquête
continuerait,
l'histoire a commencé
apparaissant dans le journal.
Un nom à la fois.
Terry Melcher certainement,
Greg Jacobson qui était
partie de la scène musicale,
mais d'autres noms aussi.
Dennis Wilson, Neil Young,
John Phillips,
Buffy Saint-Marie.
Il est devenu évident
tôt
que la musique était une grande partie
de quoi que ce soit
qui composait
Charlie Manson.
Et celui de Manson
voyage musical a commencé ici.
San Fransisco, 1967.
Une ville au coeur
d'une révolution culturelle.
Depuis la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
il était apparu
comme un phare
pour ceux qui cherchent
échapper au conservatisme
de l'Amérique centrale
et explorer des alternatives
modes de vie et attitudes,
et c'est devenu
le terrain de jeu de la côte ouest
pour les écrivains
de la Beat Generation.
Mais c'était
au milieu des années 1960
que la ville
entièrement épanouie
en tant que pôle de créativité,
sa jeunesse alimentée par la nouvelle musique,
de nouveaux médicaments et de nouvelles idées.
Et le centre névralgique
pour cette culture
et activité artistique
était
le quartier de Haight-Ashbury.
Haight-Ashbury en 1967.
En partie
c'est un peu un accident.
La scène Beat avait été
situé à North Beach.
Mais il y a une nouvelle disponibilité
de logements et de logements bon marché.
État de San Francisco
étudiants universitaires
commencer à emménager.
Et puis les artistes viennent
et ils créent un très...
C'est petit mais c'est vital,
coopérative collaborative
scène artistique à faire soi-même.
Les musiciens sont
une grande partie de cela.
Les Grateful Dead sont là
au 710 Ashbury,
Janis Joplin y habite.
L'avion Jefferson est
le premier big band
pour le frapper là.
Quand tu mets tout ça
gens créatifs ensemble
ils commencent à se nourrir
de l'énergie de l'autre.
Je pense que la grande image
est le combat
à titre personnel, artistique
et la liberté sexuelle.
Il y avait quelque chose
passe ici
ça poussait
pour des libertés élargies
à travers de nombreuses dimensions.
Bien qu'au milieu des années 1960
la croisade de la ville
pour des libertés élargies
n'était pas unique,
la force motrice
derrière sa vision particulière
de liberté était.
Alors qu'une culture jeune dynamique
avait prospéré
dans les villes d'Europe
et l'Amérique
depuis l'émergence
des Beatles
au début
de la décennie,
aucune autre scène n'avait accès
chez les Haight-Ashbury
drogue de prédilection - LSD.
Ce puissant hallucinogène
était au centre
du San Fransisco
expérience,
informer la musique,
art et idées
qui émergeaient
de la ville.
Où d'autres drogues
humeur affectée,
au LSD
la perception de la réalité par l'utilisateur
a été considérablement modifié,
et après un seul "voyage"
beaucoup ont estimé qu'ils avaient subi
un réveil spirituel.
Ça ne peut pas être
exagéré, le pouvoir du LSD.
Il a littéralement élevé les gens
d'un endroit
quelque part
complètement différent
et transformé
la vie des gens du jour au lendemain.
Tout le monde était
cherchant cette illumination,
mais le LSD était gentil
d'un raccourci.
Ça s'est en quelque sorte ouvert
le haut de ta tête
et laissez-vous voir,
ou du moins pensez que vous avez vu,
cet autre mode de vie.
Mais cela nous a aussi fait
tous très vulnérables
aux personnes qui en profitent.
Et comme les San
La contre-culture de Francisco a commencé
pour attirer les deux nationaux
et reconnaissance internationale
au début de 1967,
c'était le psychologue
Timothée Leary
qui est apparu comme le plus
défenseur éminent du LSD,
promouvoir publiquement
sa thérapeutique
et bienfaits spirituels.
Il y avait beaucoup de discussions
sur la conscience élargie.
parfois ça prenait
dimensions spirituelles très fortes
dans la façon dont les gens parlaient
sur le LSD et ses utilisations.
Leary était
le nouveau visage de cette histoire.
Tim Leary
était professeur à Harvard
qui essentiellement
est devenu l'apôtre du LSD.
Son parcours a donné
une patine d'une sorte d'autorité
à ses idées sur le LSD
et le nouveau monde,
le genre d'utopie
qu'il allait introduire.
Le message est très simple.
6 mots :
allumer, accorder, abandonner.
Son slogan est devenu :
Deviens défoncé, marijuana,
LSD.
Branchez-vous, connectez-vous
avec le genre d'images,
idées, visions
que ces médicaments vous apportent.
Et puis abandonne
de la société.
Il y avait un sentiment que
l'utopie est en marche.
C'était l'idée,
ce paradis
pourrait être récupéré
et le LSD en était la voie.
La partie abandonnée de son message
était le plus controversé.
Plus tard, il marcherait
cette déclaration en arrière un peu.
Il ne voulait pas dire abandonner.
Il voulait dire réfléchir plus fort
sur où vous mettez votre énergie.
Mais le caillou avait été
tombé dans cette eau
et ça a commencé à se répandre
de manière
que personne ne pouvait
contrôler enfin,
encore moins Timothy Leary.
Au cours de l'été 1967,
le soi-disant été de l'amour,
jeunes désenchantés
de toute l'Amérique
a commencé à tomber
sortir en masse
et ont afflué à San Francisco,
à la recherche de l'utopie
que la vision de Timothy Leary
suggéré les attendait.
Une des choses que nous oublions
est-ce que Haight-Ashbury
était un endroit si concentré.
Il aurait peut-être pu gérer
peut-être un millier de personnes
y vivre, y manger,
partie de la communauté,
mais pendant la soi-disant
L'été de l'amour
de '67 à '69,
l'estimation est à ce jour
qu'environ 300 enfants par jour
se présenterait.
Et ceux-ci étaient
ceux qui n'avaient pas d'argent,
ils n'avaient nulle part où aller,
juste la croyance si vous y arrivez
nous serons pris en charge.
C'est l'atmosphère.
Il s'est ouvert
la possibilité pour les prédateurs.
De tout le pays
sont venus les arnaqueurs,
les trafiquants de drogue, les proxénètes,
et surtout attiré
par ce magnifique terrain de chasse
est venu Charlie Manson.
Première arrivée
dans le quartier de Haight-Ashbury
au printemps 1967,
Charles Manson avait 32 ans
et tout aussi désireux de s'engager
avec l'utopie offerte
que les jeunes qui l'entourent.
Fraîchement sorti de
sept ans de prison,
comme beaucoup de ceux qui affluent
à San Fransisco,
Manson aussi cherchait
échapper à un passé trouble
et prendre un nouveau départ
dans ce nouveau monde courageux.
Né à Cincinnati, Ohio
à un adolescent célibataire,
Kathleen Maddox,
une mère capricieuse
en contradiction avec
sa famille religieuse,
le jeune Charlie Manson
n'a jamais connu son père.
Et à seulement 4 ans,
il a regardé sa mère
être emmené par la police
pour vol à main armée,
pour lequel elle recevrait
une peine de cinq ans de prison.
Manson était
chaque partie de l'enfant jetable.
Il a été passé
aux amis, à la famille,
quiconque voudrait le prendre,
et il a ensuite été envoyé
à ses grands-parents
puis sur
à sa tante et son oncle.
Donc en gros
il a fait le tour
et dès le plus jeune âge
il savait qu'il n'était pas recherché.
Il a vécu avec
sa tante, son oncle et son cousin
et sa grand-mère
est venu le voir.
Il n'y avait aucune raison de dire
que la jeunesse de Charlie
comme un enfant était idéal.
Avoir ta mère
en prison ne l'est jamais.
Mais il a toujours eu des gens aimants
qui tenait à lui.
Le problème était,
bien sûr,
que Charlie était
Depuis le début
un très désagréable,
enfant violent.
Mais bien
agressif et maussade,
chez sa tante et son oncle
ménage en Virginie-Occidentale
le jeune Charles Manson
également trouvé
un exutoire moins destructeur
pour ses énergies.
Il y avait un piano
chez son oncle et sa tante
et même en tant que petit enfant,
et tu dois te souvenir
on parle d'un garçon
qui même à 5 ans
regardé peut-être 3.
Ses mains étaient minuscules.
Mais il resterait
au clavier
et à l'oreille choisir des chansons.
Les chansons de sa vie
à ce moment-là
venait d'un
de deux catégories,
musique d'église
ou la musique country.
Il était quelque chose
d'un prodige de la musique.
Il détestait aller à l'église
sauf chanter,
et quand il chantait,
il se joindrait à
si de tout cœur
que sa grand-mère aurait
croire l'esprit du Seigneur
doit descendre
sur cet enfant.
Ce don naturel
car la musique ne suffisait pas
pour freiner la délinquance de Manson
tendances cependant.
Dans son adolescence
ses activités criminelles,
y compris le vol et le cambriolage,
l'a vu arrêté d'innombrables fois
et détenu dans
un certain nombre d'écoles de réforme
et les établissements correctionnels.
Et comme il gagnait
une éducation criminelle
pendant son incarcération,
au début de la vingtaine son principal
l'aspiration était de devenir proxénète.
Manson était
chaque bit le petit criminel.
Il ne pouvait pas vraiment organiser grand-chose
et comme sa feuille de rap se termine
il n'arrêtait pas de se faire prendre.
Charlie Manson était un échec
en tant que criminel
dans tous les sens.
Il a commencé le vol à l'étalage
et s'est toujours fait prendre.
Il volerait des voitures,
ils le retrouveraient.
Finalement, quand nous avons décidé après
apprendre le métier des proxénètes
et son premier séjour en prison
qu'il courrait
une ribambelle de filles,
il ne pourra jamais les garder
très long.
La chose qui a emporté
de son début de carrière criminelle
est un œil formidable
pour ceux qui savent manipuler.
Manson expliquerait
sa philosophie d'attirer
d'abord ses prostituées
et plus tard ses adeptes féminines
comme toujours trouver ceux
qui étaient pliés ou fissurés
mais pas complètement cassé.
Malgré une brève tentative
s'installer au milieu des années 50
qui l'a vu revenir
à la Virginie Occidentale
et épouser une serveuse locale,
instincts criminels
étaient maintenant enracinés dans Manson.
A la fin de la décennie
une tentative pour s'établir
comme proxénète au Nouveau-Mexique
une fois de plus conduit à son arrestation,
et cette fois
il a été incarcéré
au niveau isolé, moyen-
prison de sécurité McNeil Island,
sur une peine de dix ans.
Sans aucune chance d'évasion
il a appris à jouer de la guitare,
et sa passion
pour la musique retournée.
Ce n'était d'abord qu'un passe-temps.
Et puis, en 1964,
à travers la radio
il a entendu un son qui
changer complètement son regard.
♪ Oh ouais,
Je vais te dire quelque chose
♪ Je pense que tu comprendras
♪ Quand je dis que quelque chose
♪ Je veux te tenir la main
Les Beatles'
la musique était extraordinaire.
C'était vibrant.
C'était alerte.
Il vient de balayer
la jeunesse du monde
et tout le monde
qui les a croisés
A été affecté,
même s'ils ne les aimaient pas
ils étaient en quelque sorte affectés
par eux.
Il est impossible de surestimer
L'influence des Beatles
sur les musiciens en herbe,
Charles Manson parmi eux.
Mais... tout le monde,
n'importe qui de cette génération
parle des Beatles
et l'effet immédiat.
C'était énorme, instantané
et ça durait.
C'était
un moment transformateur
dans sa vie
entendre cette musique.
Ce que font les Beatles
pour Charlie Manson
est-ce qu'ils ne se contentent pas d'élargir
ses horizons musicaux,
mais ils élargissent son ambition.
Auparavant tout ce qu'il voulait être
est un souteneur à succès
où sortent les femmes
et faire tout le travail pour vous
et tu n'as pas
travailler très dur vous-même.
Maintenant tout à coup
il a une guitare,
il sait en jouer,
il a l'inspiration
et il commence
écrire des chansons en prison.
L'île Terminale,
Los Angeles.
C'est ici, en 1966,
que Manson a été transféré
terminer son séjour en prison,
son tronçon de 10 ans
réduit en raison d'un bon comportement.
Dans cette prison de basse sécurité,
Manson a rencontré Phil Kaufman,
un acteur servant un court métrage
peine pour possession de drogue.
Nous marchions
dans la cour tous les jours
entre les travaux et après le dîner
et petit-déjeuner.
Tu marches dans la cour
aller et retour.
Et ce gars était
jouer de la guitare
et il chantait
"l'ombre de ton sourire".
J'ai dit, "Wow, ce mec est cool."
♪ L'ombre de ton sourire...
Alors je me suis approché pour dire,
présentons-nous.
Et il a continué à jouer
sa guitare
et nous parlions
et un garde s'approche de lui
et dit : "Manson!
Vous ne pouvez pas jouer de la guitare ici.
"Tu dois jouer de ta guitare
là-bas dans le coin musique."
Charlie a juste continué à jouer
sa guitare.
Il est parti.
Et le garde a crié,
"Manson, tu n'es jamais
va sortir d'ici."
Charlie a dit, "Hors d'où,
homme? L'ombre de ton sourire."
Il a juste continué.
Charlie était-il cool.
Il jouait de la guitare
et j'ai chanté de la musique que j'aimais.
Il chantait des standards.
Comme je l'ai dit,
"L'ombre de ton sourire",
d'autres chansons populaires à l'époque.
Et il a bien chanté.
Il ressemblait à Frankie Laine.
C'était une grande star
retour dans les années 40
et Charlie et moi sommes
tous deux de cette époque.
Nous sommes tous les deux des gars plus âgés.
C'était notre cadre
de référence.
Nous avions Frank Sinatra,
Perry Como et ce genre.
En mars 1967,
Manson était prêt à être libéré
de l'île Terminale.
Et conscient de son
ambitions musicales,
Phil Kaufman lui a donné
les détails
d'un divertissement précieux
contact.
Quand Charly
sortait,
Je lui ai proposé de rencontrer un ami
de mon Gary Stromberg,
qui était dans le business de la musique
parce que je pensais qu'il était bon.
Encore une fois, c'est Charlie
en prison dont je parle.
Donc je prends ce personnage
et le présenter
aux gens respectables
dans le monde de la musique,
et il s'est avéré
tout le contraire.
Une fois qu'il est sorti
il dit, "jeu sur."
Ayant été incarcéré
depuis la fin
de la décennie précédente,
à sa libération
Manson a été casté
dans un tout
paysage étranger.
L'Amérique qu'il avait connue
avait été transformé
par la culture des jeunes
révolution qui a suivi
dans le sillage des Beatles.
Avec l'assassinat
de John F. Kennedy,
l'avènement de
la guerre du Vietnam
et le brouillon qui voyait
des milliers de jeunes hommes
jeté dans un conflit
ils n'y croyaient pas,
L'écart de génération
qui s'était développé dans les années 1950
était maintenant devenu un gouffre.
La contre-culture qui était
répandre à travers le pays
vu leurs aînés et les
autorités avec méfiance,
et cherchait à remodeler
le mode de vie américain.
Les gens ont réalisé
qu'en tant que nation,
nous étions spirituellement en faillite.
Nous avions perdu notre chemin.
Les principes moraux
de notre constitution
et les pères fondateurs
semblait avoir été oublié.
C'était une époque de
profonde aliénation dans le pays
en raison de l
La guerre du Vietnam,
à cause des avances
dans les droits sexuels
et une plus grande prise de conscience
de discrimination raciale
et le mouvement des droits civiques.
Il y avait une grande division,
mais je pensais
pas tant que quelque chose de négatif
mais un comme où
nous explorions de nouvelles choses.
Nous traversions tous
ce genre de phases
d'exploration
et l'innocence vraiment.
Et le joueur de 32 ans
Charles Manson
avait très envie d'exploiter
cette innocence.
En route d'abord vers Berkeley
puis à San Francisco,
la ville lui a permis de regagner
un jeune perdu dans l'enfermement,
et il embrassa
cette nouvelle culture
et son pouvoir libérateur.
À Haight-Ashbury, Manson's
première impulsion était de prendre du recul
et observer les dirigeants
de cette scène.
Sur plusieurs semaines
il écoutait les groupes locaux,
regardé les différents
prédicateurs et militants sociaux
au parc du Golden Gate
et a pris du LSD pour la première fois.
Puis il descendit le
rue avec sa guitare à la main
et a commencé à chercher
pour ses adeptes.
San Fransisco
était inondé de gourous
et philosophes, prédicateurs,
cultes, religions,
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
à chaque coin de rue.
Manson avait sa propre marque
de philosophie.
Il était connu
en tant que « jardinier ».
Il plantait des graines
dans l'esprit des gens.
Alors il a apporté un paquet
avec lui.
C'était un très
personne rusée et charismatique.
Je veux dire, il était un grand interprète
et un grand prédicateur.
Il a fait un bon numéro qui
était celui de l'intelligence cosmique,
qui franchement jamais
avait du sens pour moi
au-delà de deux ou trois phrases,
mais il l'avait quand même baissé.
Fusionner les concepts de la Bible,
La Scientologie et les gourous de l'acide
l'entourant,
La philosophie de Manson -
que la morale était un mensonge,
que rien n'était corrompu
sauf pour les possessions, l'ego
et la famille -
a commencé à attirer vers lui
un petit groupe de jeunes femmes.
Mary Brunner, Lynette Fromme,
Patricia Krenwinkel,
Susan Atkins
- tous ont été séduits
par le charisme de Manson,
sa musique et la proximité
il leur a promis.
Ce petit harem d'adeptes
agirait comme l'entourage de Manson
pour la prochaine étape de son plan.
Avec le numéro de téléphone de Phil
Contact musical de Kaufman,
Gary Stromberg,
encore à portée de main,
en novembre 1967, il acquit
un grand autobus scolaire jaune
et se dirigea vers le sud
à la Cité des Anges,
son rêve musical
brûle toujours fort.
En Californie en
particulier,
même les groupes de San Francisco
qui étaient gros
et pensé à eux-mêmes
comme une sorte d'échelon supérieur,
comme l'a dit Frank Zappa,
tout le monde devait descendre
à Los Angeles
et se salissent les mains.
C'est là que
les maisons de disques étaient,
il y a les étiquettes, il y a
les personnes qui pourraient vous signer.
Manson est allé à Los Angeles
sans but
autre que de devenir
une star du rock and roll.
Los Angeles, 1967.
Une ville tentaculaire
propulsé par son immense
industrie du divertissement.
Et même si cela avait été
le coeur de l'américain
monde du cinéma depuis des décennies,
sa croissance
en tant que capitale musicale florissante
était relativement récent
phénomène.
À l'aube
de la décennie,
l'industrie de la musique était
principalement concentré
à New York.
Pourtant, en 1961, un groupe a émergé
qui aiderait à mettre Los Angeles
sur la carte musicale.
Au milieu d'un engouement pour la côte ouest
pour surfer,
qui a produit
sa propre culture de la jeunesse locale
et son rock instrumental,
Les Beach Boys sont sortis
une série de hits
qui a apporté cette culture
à l'attention nationale.
Dirigé par le talentueux compositeur
et le chanteur Brian Wilson,
avec ses frères
et cousin à l'appui,
le son unique du groupe
les a propulsés
au sommet du monde de la musique
et a immédiatement donné
Californie un félicitations culturelles.
Les garçons de la plage
et le phénomène de la musique surf
hors de la côte ouest,
les vagues et les bronzages
et les filles en bikinis étriqués
et des go-go girls qui dansent
était quelque chose que les enfants
dans le Midwest
particulièrement étaient fascinés par.
"Je peux sortir en Californie
"et vivre
un été sans fin."
Même les gens dans le froid
Villes de la côte Est
vu cela comme une sortie,
sortie.
Les gens ont commencé à se diriger
en Californie
au début des années 60.
Les Beach Boys ont créé
cette mystique à l'échelle nationale.
♪ Si tout le monde avait un océan
♪ À travers les États-Unis
♪ Alors tout le monde surferait
♪ Comme la Californie
♪ Tu les verrais
portant leurs sacs
♪ Les sandales Huarachi aussi
♪ Une coiffure blonde touffue
♪ Surfin' U.S.A.
Ils avaient
ce genre de surf du soleil californien
qui pour tout le monde,
certainement à travers l'Amérique
et certainement à travers le monde,
c'était un paquet fantastique.
Et c'était une brochure
à un mode de vie
auquel beaucoup de gens aspiraient.
C'était donc du bon temps la musique.
♪ je me déplace, je me déplace,
Je me déplace
♪ De ville en ville se déplacer
rond rond je me déplace
♪ Je suis vraiment cool
♪ Se déplacer en rond
je me déplace...
La musique de surf avait existé,
mais c'était
musique instrumentale.
Ils n'ont jamais eu
vraiment de bonnes voix sur eux
ou voix du tout sur eux.
Tout à coup
Matchs de Brian Wilson
que Chuck Berry
énergie surf rock
avec ces harmonies étonnantes,
des harmonies qui ont
une sorte d'élément de jazz pour eux.
Il n'y avait pas eu
quelque chose comme ça.
Les Beach Boys n'ont pas seulement apporté
le charme de la Californie
aux adolescents américains.
En 1964, les maisons de disques ont commencé
ouverture de bureaux à Los Angeles
et, suite à l'impact
des Beatles
et l'invasion britannique,
télévision musicale
les spectacles étaient très demandés
et a commencé à filmer
dans les studios d'Hollywood.
Avec l'essor de l'industrie,
à LA même promoteurs
et les hommes A&R
cherchaient des groupes locaux
à propulser sous les feux de la rampe.
Entrez Les Byrds.
Les Byrds ont changé
la scène musicale de la côte ouest
pendant la nuit.
Nous avions toute cette maison de disques
et le commerce du disque
déménager
à Los Angeles en 1964
mais les Byrds
à peu près défini
quel avenir pour la musique
allait être.
Ils ont pris le rythme des Beatles
et le son d'harmonie des Beatles
puis mélangé avec
La profondeur lyrique de Bob Dylan.
♪ Hé Monsieur Tambourin Man,
Joue une chanson pour moi
♪ Je n'ai pas sommeil et il n'y a pas
aucun endroit où je vais...
Vous avez eu une progression à L.A.
Les Beach Boys étaient
important au début des années 60
et continuerait
être aussi.
Mais qu'est-ce que les Beach Boys
représentée
au moment où les Byrds
est venu semblait vieille école,
ce plaisir et le soleil et
le surf et tout ce business.
Ce sentiment de contre-culture
vision d'un nouveau monde.
C'était en quelque sorte inscrit
dans ce que faisaient les Byrds.
♪ Un temps d'amour, un temps de haine
♪ Un temps de guerre, un temps de paix
♪ Un moment que vous pouvez embrasser...
Les Byrds
transformé une sensibilité pop
avec un thème beaucoup plus profond,
qui vraiment jusqu'à
fin 1964
personne d'autre ne l'avait fait dans la pop.
Dylan l'avait fait
mais il était toujours un artiste populaire.
Il n'avait vraiment pas pénétré
les hautes sphères de la pop.
On parle de "Teen Beat"
ou magazine "16",
il ne figurait pas là-dedans,
mais les Byrds l'étaient.
Les Byrd étaient
certainement quelque chose
c'était plus des années 60,
plus moderne.
Ils avaient plus un look hippie.
C'était pré-hippie
mais Crosby portait sa cape
et McGuinn portait
ses drôles de lunettes de soleil
et ils ont regardé
un peu nerveux.
Ils avaient un son cool.
C'était tellement parfait
et juste pour l'époque.
Et les Byrds
succès bientôt inspiré
un certain nombre d'autres groupes locaux,
dont Les Portes,
Amour et Frank Zappa
et ses mères de l'invention.
Avec de la marijuana plus facilement
disponible en Californie
que sur la côte Est
ou en Bretagne,
ces actes tous partagés
une sensibilité souterraine,
une mystique lapidée
qui les distinguait
du monde pop.
Et ils se sont développés dans le cadre
d'une scène fleurie,
son centre d'activité
le tronçon d'un demi-mile de clubs
et restaurants
à Hollywood Ouest
connue sous le nom de Sunset Strip.
Ici, dans des lieux comme
le Whisky a Go-Go,
l'ancien ordre hollywoodien
était en cours de démantèlement
et les graines
du mouvement hippie à venir
étaient semés.
Oh, c'était tout.
Le Strip était... il y avait
le Whisky et le Trip
et puis il y en a eu moins
clubs de haut en bas du Strip.
Le Strip était le cœur,
la Mecque, où tu es allé.
Vous étiez l'un ou l'autre
de ces gens qui étaient branchés,
fumer de l'herbe et tout ça.
Mais pour ces gens
qui n'étaient pas du tout dedans...
Oh mec! Ils étaient comme
d'une autre planète.
Tu ne pouvais même pas leur parler.
Précédemment
des jours comme le Sunset Strip
quand le Trocadéro et le
Mocambo et les Ciro's originaux,
c'étaient des boîtes de nuit exclusives
où les riches et Hollywood
stars de cinéma sont allés.
Et tu avais des photos de Charlie
Chaplin et Marilyn Monroe
et tous les grands noms là-bas
mais ce n'était pas vraiment accessible
au "Joe" normal.
Vous savez, vous verriez ces
photos dans les magazines de cinéma
et c'est à peu près tout.
Maintenant ce groupe de personnes
avait vieilli.
Ils avaient commencé à jouer
à Las Vegas
et adolescents
envahi les boîtes de nuit.
Il ne semblait pas
être cette séparation.
Les musiciens
faisaient leur truc
et le public
faisait leur truc
mais c'était tout
la même chose.
Nous devenions défoncés.
Nous étions à l'écoute de cela
autoroute vers l'illumination.
Les gens étaient juste
communier les uns avec les autres,
à la fois mentalement, physiquement.
Nous étions dedans ensemble.
Et c'était dans
ce nouveau monde branché
que Charles Manson et ses quatre
les adeptes féminines sont arrivées en retard
Organiser immédiatement une réunion
avec le contact de Phil Kaufman,
Gary Stromberg, qui était un talent
dépisteur pour Uni Records,
Manson a préparé son meilleur travail
pour l'audition.
Et Stromberg
a été assez impressionné
réserver une heure
longue session d'enregistrement
à l'illustre
Studios d'étoile d'or,
le lieu d'où
producteurs Phil Spector
et les Beach Boys
Brian Wilson
avait enregistré
leur œuvre la plus connue.
La première
session d'enregistrement que nous connaissons
pour Charles Manson est
pour la filiale Universal Records
Dossiers universitaires.
La bande existe remarquablement.
C'est inédit
ce qui est inhabituel...
et il présente un brut,
sans instruction ... musicien ambulant
aperçu de 20 chansons étranges...
sans aucune orientation,
forme ou structure que ce soit.
Salut, Charlie bébé.
C'est très bien.
D'ACCORD.
Voyons...
Fais ce que tu veux
tu as envie de faire, mec.
Ouais.
Juste du groove, tu sais.
Dis-nous quand tu vas commencer
et nous allons allumer la machine.
Bon, ben tu sais...
Tu ne peux pas juste l'allumer
et laisser tomber ?
D'ACCORD. Allaient
laisser tomber tout de suite.
Et puis sortez ce que vous voulez
et le reste le jette.
J'étais
surpris par la voix de Manson.
ça parait différent
puis la voix
qu'il avait
quand on lui a parlé...
qui devait être
un an ou deux plus tard, en prison.
Il était plus joueur.
Il... a beaucoup rigolé.
Et il semblait nerveux.
Si je peux me rendre nerveux...
je devrais pouvoir
pour me rendre nerveux.
Et il est logique que
ça marche dans les deux sens, non ?
Il semble
plus jeune qu'il ne l'était à l'époque.
Vous savez qu'il est dans la... mi-trentaine.
Et il a l'air
il est au début de la vingtaine
peut-être quand vous l'écoutez.
Mais il est aussi nerveux comme l'enfer.
Et tu connais le
genre de commande, si vous savez,
si quelqu'un te disait,
"Eh bien, tu connais ce gars
"Ça va être comme..."
mettre de côté le meurtrier
et tous les autres trucs
mais, "chef de secte".
Tu sais qu'il va être
commander les gens
et leur faisant faire n'importe quoi
il veut qu'ils fassent.
Cela semble tout simplement absurde.
Il a comme des idées pour une chanson,
il a des petits croquis
dans sa tête
et certains d'entre eux vraiment
ont du potentiel.
Ils semblent pouvoir
devenir quelque chose.
♪ Votre maison est
où tu es heureux
♪ Ce n'est pas là que tu n'es pas libre
♪ Votre maison est là où
tu peux être ce que tu es
♪ Parce que tu étais
juste né pour être
♪ Vous pouvez avoir un château
♪ Et des diamants à la vue de tous
♪ Mais, tu ne montreras jamais
vous leur tranquillité d'esprit
♪ Parce qu'ils ne savent pas
comment être libre
♪ Alors brûle...
Votre maison est l'endroit où vous êtes heureux.
C'est fascinant
oeuvre.
C'était très attrayant
aux jeunes
sans domicile visible
ou pas d'arrière-plan visible
ou pas de structure visible
ou quelque chose
ils ont été éloignés de
parce qu'ils savaient
leur maison n'était pas heureuse.
Ils savaient
ils n'étaient pas libres à la maison.
Pour qu'ils puissent acheter
Le monde utopique de Manson
à travers la chanson.
♪ Cela vous dérangerait-il
si je t'approche
♪ Avec cette chanson puis-je vous dire
que je t'ai regardé
♪ Combien de temps
que je t'ai regardé de loin
♪ Et maintenant tu es là,
si près de moi
♪ Maintenant je sais que ce n'est pas correct...
Il y a une influence latine.
Il y a une influence Jazz
dans ses affaires.
J'ai été très surpris d'entendre
en fait la douceur
de certains des arrangements
ou éventuellement
ces dispositions
avait une douceur pour eux
que je ne ferais jamais
ont deviné
ça aurait été
sortant de Charlie.
Les séances n'ont pas
convaincre Uni Records
que Manson était prêt
pour un contrat d'enregistrement.
Prendre le rejet
dans sa foulée,
lui et sa famille
cherché un logement,
et trouvé un logement temporaire
dans une maison communale
une courte promenade
de la plage de Topanga,
connu sous le nom d'escalier en colimaçon.
Partage de la propriété
avec divers vagabonds,
les toxicomanes et les décrocheurs,
Manson et les filles se sont installés
dans une vie commune.
Et pendant qu'il passait du temps
travailler sa musique,
Manson a également profité de l'occasion
pour rechercher de nouvelles recrues.
En décembre 1967,
Dianne Lake, décrocheuse de 14 ans
assisté à une fête
à la maison de l'escalier en colimaçon
et est devenu une proie facile
pour une ex-détenue qui a deux fois son âge.
Charlie arrive,
me donne un... tu sais,
partage sa root beer avec moi,
qui était apparemment
vraiment un honneur.
Et m'invite à venir
et vous savez...
s'asseoir en cercle
et chanter avec eux.
Il jouait de la guitare et
les filles étaient toutes autour
et ils sont tous venus, m'ont embrassé,
m'a fait sentir vraiment le bienvenu.
Plus tard, Charlie m'a pris sous
son aile et sous son charme
et il m'a séduit.
Il était drôle. Il était espiègle,
enfantin, joueur.
Tu sais qu'il avait ça...
il secouait la tête
et ses cheveux seraient
genre de danse autour d'un peu.
Je veux dire, il pensait qu'il était...
J'étais attiré par lui.
Je pensais qu'il était beau.
Accueilli instantanément
par les autres filles
dans la troupe de Manson,
la jeune Dianne est rapidement tombée dedans
avec les rituels du groupe
des hallucinogènes
et la musique, l'apprentissage
chaque mot des chansons de Charlie
et les rejoindre dans
leurs représentations collectives.
Je pense que nous avons pris
acide au moins une fois par semaine.
On s'asseyait en cercle
et Charlie serait en quelque sorte
l'administrer, comme un sacrement.
Il le placerait sur ta langue
et faire le tour du cercle.
Je veux dire, c'était...
c'était spécial.
Et la plupart des voyages
etait bon.
Et la plupart d'entre eux
étaient centrés sur la musique.
J'ai apprécié sa musique.
À ce moment-là,
un artiste solo avec sa guitare
n'était pas si rare.
Mais en 1968,
Charlie a commencé à s'interroger
si ses chances de réussir
dans le monde de la musique
peut être amélioré
s'il avait un groupe derrière lui.
De la maison de l'escalier en colimaçon
et le long de Sunset Strip,
Manson a passé le mot
qu'il formait un groupe
et cherche jeune,
musiciens doués.
L'un des premiers à se présenter
pour une audition
à la maison communale
près de la plage de Topanga
était le guitariste Ernest Knapp.
C'était effrayant,
dès le départ.
Il avait ce sentiment à son sujet
c'était... juste inconfortable.
Bizarrement, je n'ai pas auditionné
avec les autres musiciens.
Je viens d'auditionner pour Charlie
et sa famille.
je me suis installé au milieu
du sol du salon.
Pose mon ampli
et l'a branché.
Trois des filles
avait des instruments à percussion...
shakers et un tambourin
et un petit tambour
et étaient en fait
m'accompagner.
Alors... ce que j'ai aimé.
C'était...
Je prendrai toute l'aide que je peux obtenir,
Vous savez.
Knapp a été invité
rejoindre le groupe,
et la semaine suivante
est revenu répéter
avec Manson
ensemble rapidement monté.
Une fois nous avions quelques chansons
nous savions que nous pouvions jouer...
« Alors, OK, Charlie, qu'est-ce que tu as ?
Et il a exécuté
ses affaires pour nous.
Je pensais qu'il avait du talent.
J'ai pensé à ses chansons
étaient viables.
C'était plus un
Présentation de l'auteur-compositeur-interprète.
Nommer le groupe
La voie Lactée,
le lendemain, ils ont joué
leur seul et unique public
performance -
une audition
pour le créneau du samedi soir
au bar en direct local,
le corral de Topanga.
Nous nous sommes tous rencontrés là-bas
et chargé
dans quelques voitures
et roula jusqu'au Corral,
qui était à l'époque un pays
et bar à bières occidentales
plus haut dans le canyon.
Mais nous étions probablement
l'un des premiers groupes hippies
pour essayer d'y jouer.
Et c'était
dans l'après-midi
et il y avait quelques gars
assis autour,
et ils étaient
pas très gentil à ce sujet.
Ils ont dit... non.
Manson est seulement
jamais un groupe était mort-né,
et il s'est recentré sur son travail
en tant qu'artiste solo.
Malgré son échec,
le projet l'avait amené
en contact avec un autre
jeune musicien confiant.
Bobby Beausoleil, qui
s'est vanté de ses affiliations
au groupe Love
et ses jam sessions de fin de soirée
avec Franck Zappa,
deviendrait une présence sporadique
autour de la famille
au cours des deux prochaines années.
Il était
plus talentueux que Charlie.
Tous ceux qui ont vu
les deux ensemble
serait d'accord, mais
Beausoleil en tant qu'artiste créateur
certainement vu
il y avait beaucoup de créativité
dans Charlie Manson
et il y avait un certain lien
qui s'est formé entre eux.
Ils partageaient une symétrie musicale.
Ils avaient une vision similaire.
Ils ont complété
l'un à l'autre assez bien.
Mais Bobby Beausoleil
était un mâle fort.
Il avait le sien
esprit indépendant.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui s'intégrait vraiment
avec la famille de Manson.
Alors pendant qu'ils marchaient
chemins similaires,
Beausoleil n'a jamais été
un membre de la famille Manson.
Mais il était bien connecté.
Alors que Manson cherchait à passer à autre chose
de l'escalier en colimaçon,
Beausoleil a suggéré
la famille se dirige vers le nord
dans le canyon de Topanga,
et emménager dans
une propriété vide
où il avait séjourné
dans Horseshoe Drive.
Ici, en mars 1968, la famille
ont été rejoints par Phil Kaufman,
Co-détenu de Manson
à l'île Terminale,
qui était à nouveau un homme libre.
Quand je suis sorti en 1968,
Gary Stromberg connaissait un autre gars
Je savais, Harold True.
Harold avait été en contact
avec Charly.
Alors quand je suis sorti,
Harold m'a emmené à Charlie.
Quand je l'ai rencontré pour la première fois...
Ce n'était pas le gars
Je savais dans la cour
en chantant
"L'ombre de ton sourire".
Aussi impressionné qu'il était
par Manson's
harem de femmes,
Kaufmann
a également été étonné
à la métamorphose
dans sa musique.
Et dans les compositions
eux-mêmes,
il pouvait voir comment ces
nouvelles chansons que Charlie écrivait
étaient utilisés
pour séduire plus de followers...
Il avait un message.
Ils ont un sens,
une sorte de sens de joueur de flûte.
Charlie est parti de Frankie Lane
à une sorte de musique acide.
Il s'en servait.
C'était un outil, parce que
des jeunes plus jeunes que lui,
tout le monde était
plus jeune que lui,
étaient dans la nouvelle musique
alors il a mis ses paroles
à une sorte de type folk
parce qu'il n'avait pas de groupe.
Et "Regarde ton jeu Girl"
était la chose...
"Regarde ton jeu fille,
viens avec moi."
♪ Il y a un temps pour vivre
Le temps continue de voler
♪ Pensez que vous aimez bébé...
"Regarder votre
Game Girl" est le plus complexe
de tous les Manson
chansons de cette époque.
C'est multicouche,
ça s'harmonise avec sa guitare.
Il a des rythmes différents.
Sa gamme de voix
est considérable sur eux.
C'est donc très...
C'est difficile à dire,
compte tenu de ce que nous savons
à propos de Manson,
mais c'est très bien fait
oeuvre.
Ces sentiments sont-ils réels
♪ Regarde ton jeu, fille
♪ Quel délire fou...
Il vendait quelque chose.
Il le vendait.
Et ils l'ont acheté.
Ces filles étaient perdues.
Ces enfants étaient perdus.
Et le truc hippie, la paix
et l'amour, c'était son appât.
Mais l'ambiance
à Topanga n'était pas sinistre.
La paix et l'amour régnaient,
et la famille commençait
à découvrir
Conception de Manson
d'une vie commune
libre de tout souci matériel.
Avec plus de nouveaux membres
rejoindre le bercail,
il leur a appris
comment vivre modestement,
se nourrir
en visitant les dépotoirs.
Les temps étaient bons,
et ces activités collectives
trouveraient leur chemin
dans les chansons elles-mêmes.
Tu n'es pas pauvre,
vous avez une tente poubelle.
Tu ne mourras jamais de faim, aussi longtemps
comme vous avez un dépotoir.
Vous achetez un morceau de fromage.
Il date d'aujourd'hui.
Vous ne pouvez pas le vendre demain.
Il n'y a rien de mal à cela.
Vous pouvez le ramener à la maison
et mettez-le au réfrigérateur.
Et c'est ce que Manson ou moi avons fait.
J'étais avec lui.
Tu sais,
au début c'était comme euh !
Parce que certaines des bennes à ordures
étaient, vous savez, puants.
Ils ne sont pas nettoyés,
ils ne sont pas arrosés
régulièrement.
Mais, vous savez, il y avait
beaucoup de carton là-dedans.
Il y avait aussi de la nourriture.
Je veux dire, tu sais, certains
d'eux, tu sais...
Tu apprendrais quand
ils ont jeté la nourriture,
vous savez, à quelle heure.
Et donc certaines des choses
faisait encore froid.
Nous mangions
Les ordures de l'Amérique, si vous voulez.
♪ Quand tu vis sur la route
♪ Et tu penses
parfois tu meurs de faim
♪ Sortez de ce voyage mon ami
♪ Entrez simplement dans ces canettes
et commencer à sculpter
♪ Oh dépotoir
mon dépotoir
♪ Pourquoi t'appelles-tu
mon dépotoir...
Si tu veux
pour voir ce que Charlie Manson
aurait voulu
le monde pour se voir comme,
c'est l'image.
Pas l'image d'un monstre
qui pourrait faire des robots stupides
sortir et tuer
mais comme un être merveilleux
qui pourrait exister pratiquement
rien et être plus riche
que tout le monde
qui avait toutes les choses
cela pourrait autrement
le regarder de haut.
Mais même si l'atmosphère
au sein du groupe
était tranquille,
pour Phil Kaufman,
Les sermons constants de Manson
devenait intolérable.
j'ai vieilli, toi
sais, j'ai vieilli et je suis devenu plus sage.
Et heureusement
je me suis vraiment renseigné
et j'ai vu l'écriture
sur le bloc cellulaire.
C'était l'heure
sortir de là
et me séparer de lui.
Le jour où j'ai quitté un de mes amis
est venu me chercher
et il a dit,
"Je dois venir, Charlie."
Il a dit : "Oui, je sais.
« Tu penses encore,
n'est-ce pas ?"
J'ai dit : "Oui,
Je vais continuer."
Sermons et activités communautaires
ont peut-être rempli leur temps,
mais Manson tenait aussi
nouer des contacts musicaux.
Alors qu'il tentait
se côtoyer
avec la communauté rock
vivre dans
et autour de Topanga Canyon,
il a également envoyé ses partisans
au Sunset Strip.
Ici, ils étaient
pour attirer l'attention
de tous les musiciens
ils peuvent rencontrer
et effet
une introduction à Manson.
Et en mai 1968,
deux des filles ont frappé la saleté.
C'était Jo
Bailey, connu sous le nom de Yeller,
et Pat Krenwinkel,
marchant sur la route
dans l'attelage Hollywood.
Une voiture s'arrête pour les récupérer.
Un jeune beau mec dit :
« Hé, les filles, avez-vous besoin d'un tour ?
Il propose de retourner à
sa place pour le lait et les biscuits.
Ils pensent qu'ils savent exactement
ce que cela veut dire,
donc quand ils reviennent
chez lui,
qui est vraiment
un endroit spectaculaire,
juste à côté du coucher du soleil,
il offre vraiment
eux du lait et des biscuits.
Et au bout d'un moment,
il dit qu'il doit y aller,
il espère voir
eux à nouveau parfois.
Il est dans un groupe
appelé les Beach Boys.
Ils y retournent consciencieusement et...
Charlie demande,
« Avez-vous rencontré quelqu'un ?
"Eh bien, il y a ce gars
qui est venu nous chercher
"et nous a ramenés chez lui,
Vous savez..."
"Dans quel groupe était-il ?"
"Les garçons de la plage."
Et Charlie... c'est tout.
Il saute
hors de ses vêtements.
«Où est la maison de ce type?»
Le garçon de la plage
ils avaient involontairement
trébuché sur
était Dennis Wilson, le batteur
et petit frère
du groupe est célèbre
producteur et auteur-compositeur Brian.
Cette nuit-là, Manson
et toute sa famille sont partis
pour la propriété de Wilson
sur Sunset Boulevard,
envie de faire bonne impression.
Denis Wilson
au milieu de la nuit,
Retour a la maison,
tire dans son allée
et les lumières sont allumées
dans sa maison.
Et il y a un bus scolaire
garé là.
Il y a des gens chez lui.
Il sort de sa voiture
et il entre prudemment
parce que c'est un homme riche.
On ne sait jamais
ce qui va être là.
Et sort ce petit
mec petit avec une barbe,
"Salut mec, comment ça va?"
agir comme un hôte.
Et les premiers mots
de la bouche de Dennis sont,
"Est-ce que tu vas me faire du mal"
Et Charlie Manson
s'agenouille
et il embrasse
Le pied de Dennis Wilson.
"Est-ce que j'ai l'air de quelqu'un
qui va te faire du mal, mec ?
"Entre." Et Dennis s'en va
et ils sont dans sa maison.
C'est la famille Manson
faire comme chez soi.
Avec des filles à moitié nues
étendu autour de sa maison,
Denis Wilson
fut instantanément enchanté
par Manson et ses partisans.
De tous les Beach Boys,
ils s'étaient rencontrés sans le savoir
celui qui serait
les plus ouverts à leurs charmes.
Denis Wilson
était 100% différent
du reste du groupe
d'une manière importante.
Il était l'athlète.
C'était le gars
qui est sorti et a surfé,
et bien sur
les filles l'aimaient le plus.
Il était, tu sais,
très robuste beau
et il s'entendait bien avec les femmes.
Les autres gars étaient comme,
Brian est un peu grand et gonflé,
et Carl est potelé
et prendre des cours de guitare,
et Al va être dentiste,
et Mike travaille
dans une station-service.
Il est un peu comme
le chanteur connard.
Dennis Wilson a incarné
ce qu'étaient les Beach Boys.
Leurs premières chansons
parlaient de surf et de voitures.
Brian Wilson écrivait des chansons
sur la vie de Denis.
Et la famille
avait fait irruption dans la vie de Wilson
à un moment parfait.
L'année dernière
Les Beach Boys avaient souffert
une série de publicités
déceptions,
avec leur génie Brian Wilson
perdre le contrôle artistique
de la bande
et mentalement en difficulté
suite à son utilisation prolongée
du LSD.
Essayer de rafraîchir leur fatigue
image dans le nouveau monde branché,
dans les semaines avant
la famille Manson est arrivée
Denis avait été
sur la route pour un tour
qui a jumelé le groupe
avec le Maharishi Mahesh Yogi.
Cet éminent gourou indien avait
été élevé au rang de superstar
suite à son implication
avec les Beatles,
encore la combinaison
de ses discours
sur la Méditation Transcendantale
avec un spectacle rock and roll
échoué sans surprise
pour avoir un impact.
Ce fut un désastre.
Les gens qui veulent
voir Les Beach Boys
Je ne veux pas voir Maharishi,
et les gens
qui veulent voir Maharishi
je ne veux pas voir
Les garçons de la plage.
Cela n'a pas fonctionné.
Idée intéressante,
mais ce fut un échec.
68 a été une année difficile pour eux
La tournée Maharishi
était un désastre.
Ils ont eu des problèmes
avec l'élément sud
de leur tournée
à cause de Martin Luther
Assassinat du roi.
Ils perdaient de l'argent,
ils faisaient une hémorragie d'argent.
Les disques ne se vendaient pas.
Ils ne rattrapaient vraiment pas
culturellement avec les gens.
Ils portaient encore
tenues assorties sur scène.
Ainsi, en 1968,
Les Beach Boys étaient perçus
comme faisant partie du passé.
Dennis n'était pas intéressé
en faisant partie du passé.
Un jeune homme
toujours à l'affût de nouvelles idées,
il avait été fasciné
par les enseignements du Maharishi
et cherchait
plus de sens à sa vie.
Les prédications de Manson
dénoncer les possessions matérielles
et célébrer la commune
et l'unité spirituelle,
avec l'attrait sexuel
des filles,
l'a conquis immédiatement,
et il les a tous invités
pour le rejoindre
à son 14400,
Maison Sunset Boulevard.
Dennis était un gars amusant.
je me souviens de lui
être une sorte d'homme sauvage,
il aimait... aimait
voitures rapides, femmes rapides.
Il aimait vivre
dans la voie rapide.
Dennis venait de sortir
de retraite ou quelque chose
avec le yogi Maharishi
donc je pense qu'il...
Et Charlie est en forme
ce gourou...
Je pense que Dennis cherchait
pour ce genre d'inspiration.
Denis était
toujours à la recherche de plus.
Il cherchait toujours
pour la suite,
et il était comme un enfant dans
de cette façon.
Et je pense que ces
les gens l'intéressaient vraiment.
Une partie de la chose pour Dennis
à ce moment-là
était qu'il nourrissait une certaine
coupable pour tout ce qu'il avait,
pour toute la richesse et les pièges
qui est venu avec.
Je ne pense pas qu'il ait jamais ressenti
comme il le méritait.
Je pense qu'il avait l'impression d'avoir
tout ça
essentiellement parce que
de son frère.
Et tous ces trucs
vient de lui venir,
pas par son propre travail acharné
ou non par son propre talent,
mais juste par chance.
Wilson avait seulement déménagé
dans son tentaculaire, loué
propriété sur Sunset Boulevard
récemment suite à la panne
de son premier mariage.
Avec Manson
et son harem errant
maintenant des invités permanents,
il a contacté son ami proche
et collaborateur Gregg Jakobson
et l'a invité à la fête...
Ma première exposition à l'assistant,
comme Dennis l'appellerait,
est-ce qu'il m'a appelé un soir,
« Gregg, tu as
descendre ici.
"Tu dois voir ce gars.
C'est le sorcier
"et il a toutes ces filles."
Pour moi c'était,
"OK, Den, je l'ai déjà entendu.
"Des filles et une fête. Je suis marié.
J'ai deux enfants."
Donc je n'ai jamais répondu
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit un jour,
peut-être une semaine plus tard
quand ils étaient beaucoup plus
une partie de toute la scène
là-bas à la maison.
Je dois dire ceci. Quand Charly
était là, il avait une énergie.
Tu ne pouvais pas
faites attention à Charlie.
C'était une personne sympathique.
Il était très charmant
et il a fait attention à vous.
Je peux comprendre pourquoi Dennis
l'appelait "le sorcier"
parce qu'il avait
cette capacité unique
pour te faire sentir comme
tu étais... il était inquiet.
Tu étais important.
Il ne s'est pas contenté de vous éclairer.
Juste vivre
sur ce domaine était magique.
Je me souviens m'être défoncé
et boire comme
jus d'orange ou jus de raisin
c'était juste, euh... paradisiaque.
N'oubliez pas,
Dennis avait quitté sa maison
et sa famille
et sa femme et tout.
Maintenant il avait toute cette adoration
et toutes ces filles.
Ils lui fabriquaient des vêtements
et ils ont presque
se prosternerait devant lui.
Donc je suis sûr
pour l'instant
il était très charmé
par toute la scène.
Mais ce n'était pas
tout sur le sexe, la drogue
et conscience élargie -
Wilson était aussi fasciné
par la musique de Manson.
Et avec son frère aîné Brian
se retirer de son rôle
comme la conduite des Beach Boys
force, les autres membres du groupe
tenaient à trouver leur
propre voix au sein du groupe,
rien de plus que Dennis.
À l'époque
il développait ses compétences
sur le clavier.
Il viendrait le matin
et pratiquer et arranger les choses
et parfois Brian
aiderait et lui montrerait des choses,
mais la plupart du temps
il expérimentait tout seul.
Alors il était différent
des autres gars
qui étaient familiers
avec accords et transitions
et ce genre de chose.
Mais il était extrêmement doué,
il apprenait vite.
1968 était la première fois
il était même regardé
comme quelque chose de sérieux musicalement
et Brian
permettait aux autres
pour montrer ce qu'ils avaient.
Et Dennis montrait
le talent pour écrire des chansons.
C'est un novice mais c'est évident
qu'il y a quelque chose là-bas.
Les garçons de la plage
avait aussi récemment
installation
leur propre maison de disques,
Brother Records, avec
un œil pour recruter de nouveaux talents
qui serait
mieux refléter l'époque
que leur propre acte périmé.
Impressionné par
les talents musicaux de Manson,
Wilson espérait à la fois apprendre de
et collaborer
avec son nouvel invité.
C'était probablement la première fois
que Dennis s'est intéressé
dans quelqu'un
et la musique en même temps,
presque comme un producteur
commencerait à envisager
comment vous traitez avec un artiste
et je pense que c'était
d'où venait Dennis
et il s'est rendu compte
qu'il avait vraiment quelque chose
qu'il pourrait apporter
à la table.
Et ainsi il est devenu musicalement
Le mentor de Charlie, disons.
En premier lieu, la relation
qui les unissait
était la musique.
Ce dont je me souviens c'est que
il aimait vraiment Charlie.
Je veux dire, il a présenté Charlie
à ses amis.
Charlie lui apprenait
comment jouer de la guitare
et lui, tu sais, c'était gentil
d'une admiration mutuelle...
bromance ou autre.
C'est ce que je me souviens avoir vu,
c'est que je pense
ils s'aimaient sincèrement.
Ça à du être
un peu de justification
pour que Manson soit pris
sérieusement par quelqu'un
aussi connu que Dennis.
Même si Denis
ne s'était pas vraiment développé
en tant qu'artiste encore,
Denis était une superstar.
Soudain, vous collaboriez
avec quelqu'un
qui était très connu
et vient d'une famille
qui est énormément respecté
dans l'industrie.
Avec Gregg Jakobson,
Wilson tenait aussi
Présenter
son nouvel invité dynamique
et collaborateur
à un autre ami,
producteur de disques Terry Melcher.
Le fils de Doris Day
et le partenaire de l'étoile montante
Candice Bergen,
avec son rôle de premier plan
sur la scène musicale de LA
Melcher était un lien vital entre
Hollywood d'hier et d'aujourd'hui.
Terry Melcher était quelqu'un
qui faisait vraiment partie
d'Hollywood
scène de divertissement
et, vous savez, il a produit
les deux premiers albums de Byrds,
qui sont extrêmement importants.
Il était très impliqué
avec Paul Revere & The Raiders,
qui étaient de grands fabricants de succès
à l'époque.
Je veux dire, tout le monde savait
qui était Terry Melcher.
Et donc pour obtenir sa bénédiction
ou pour susciter son intérêt
aurait été un gros gain
pour tout auteur-compositeur en herbe.
Au cours des prochains mois,
Manson est devenu assez proche
à Melcher
qu'il ait été invité
à la propriété Beverley Hills
le producteur a loué
dans Cielo Drive.
Bien que Melcher et Jakobson
étaient ses visiteurs les plus fréquents,
La maison de Denis Wilson
était un lieu de rencontre populaire
pour de nombreux musiciens de renom.
La maison de Denis
était un point de rassemblement.
Étant très libéral,
et les gens se sont sentis les bienvenus
et pourrait tomber dans
à toute heure,
tant de gens
appelé Dennis,
et évidemment en collision
avec la famille Manson.
Les goûts de Stephen Stills,
Glenn Campbell.
Neil Diamond en était un autre.
Neil Young, fraîchement sorti
de Buffalo Springfield,
est tombé sur Manson
et il a été bluffé
par le jeu musical de Manson.
Si l'on en croit les rapports,
il était enchanté par Manson.
Il lui a acheté une moto.
Je l'ai emmené rencontrer Warners,
qui si comptes
sont à croire,
n'était pas si impressionné.
Donc je pense que Manson est aimable
présence enchantait les gens.
Le problème avec Manson est
une fois que vous avez rebondi
sur bande, il perd tout.
Alors ce qu'il te reste
avec quelques chansons.
Vous n'avez pas
Manson le personnage,
tu n'as pas Manson,
les filles...
Ce qui a enchanté les gens
était le paquet.
Maintenant un chiffre accepté
dans les hautes sphères
de la contre-culture LA,
La présence de Manson aux fêtes
et les clubs sont devenus courants.
Et au centre névralgique
de la scène,
sur le Sunset Strip
et son lieu de prédilection
le Whisky A-Go-Go,
il a fait
une impression ineffaçable...
Il y avait
un incident au Whisky.
Une nuit nous étions tous là
à la table.
Charlie était venu avec nous.
Denis était là.
Terry Melcher était là.
Alors nous étions tous là,
boire de la bière
et passer un bon moment.
Et nous avons remarqué
un peu d'agitation
venant de la piste de danse.
Et le whisky est plein à craquer.
Les filles étaient dans les cages
à l'époque au Whisky
et le groupe joue à fond.
Le groupe est vraiment dedans
parce qu'il se passe quelque chose.
Je me suis levé sur la chaise.
Je me suis levé à l'arrière
de la cabine et j'ai dit,
"Hey les gars,
tu dois voir ça."
C'était Charlie au milieu
de la piste de danse
et il avait littéralement effacé
la piste de danse du Whisky.
Je veux dire, les gens tiraient lentement
retour jusqu'à...
Et je jure devant Dieu à ce jour
ça ressemblait à de l'électricité
sortait de lui.
Je veux dire, ce genre d'énergie
et il a littéralement soufflé
tout le monde loin
seul sur la piste de danse.
Personne ne pouvait même s'approcher
à danser avec lui.
Mais c'était Charlie.
Il avait ça
l'explosivité, cette énergie.
Bien qu'il ait été
faire sa marque sur la scène,
à la fin de l'été
Manson et sa famille
avaient dépassé leur accueil
chez Dennis Wilson.
En août Les Beach Boys
embarquaient
sur une longue tournée
des États-Unis et du Canada
pour promouvoir leur dernier album,
et Wilson a décidé
ce serait le moment idéal
pour ses invités
aller de l'avant.
La fête devait finir un jour
et ça coûtait à Dennis
une fortune
et si tous les comptes
sont à croire
c'était 100 000 $ en nourriture,
traitement de la gonorrhée,
vêtements perdus tout.
Ils le saignaient à sec.
on m'a dit
par le PA de Dennis.
"Je vais sur la route.
Pouvez-vous... nous trouver un nouvel endroit ?"
Il dit: "Je veux mes affaires
hors de là."
Charlie n'avait pas vraiment le choix.
La maison a été fermée.
je l'ai fermé
pendant que Dennis était parti.
Il est revenu
quelques semaines plus tard
à une nouvelle maison.
Leur amitié et
la collaboration musicale s'est poursuivie,
et Manson a profité de l'occasion
pour déménager sa famille grandissante
dans un lieu plus isolé.
Spah Ranch,
30 milles au nord
de la maison de Dennis à Santa Monica,
était une fois
un lieu de cinéma en plein essor
à l'apogée du western
films de la décennie précédente.
Maintenant largement inactif, il s'est avéré
parfait pour les besoins de Manson.
Chefs de secte
peut toujours être identifié
par quelques choses qu'ils font
et Manson les a tous faits.
La première chose est que
il faut trouver des gens
qui se sentent abusés,
les persécuter et les convaincre
que tu connais le chemin
pour les protéger, mais seulement vous.
La deuxième chose que vous essayez de faire
c'est les isoler.
Vous devez les obtenir
loin des voix extérieures.
Familles, amis, médias.
Quiconque dirait,
"Attendez une minute,
ce mec est un cinglé."
Vous voulez arriver à un point
où la seule voix
ils entendent est à vous.
Ça ne marchera pas
chez Dennis Wilson.
Spah Ranch,
juste à l'extérieur de Los Angeles,
et si vous entendez
la distance parcourue,
ce n'est pas si long que ça.
Tu penses,
"Ça va être du smog
"et plus de ces bâtiments."
Mais c'est du vrai genre
de cet espace naturel
ça a l'air
c'est la frontière.
C'est le pays.
C'est aussi éloigné de
une grande ville comme vous pouvez l'imaginer.
Et pourtant c'est seulement
environ 25 minutes en voiture.
Charlie peut toujours atteindre
Los Angeles
mais il peut isoler
ses partisans.
Au Spahn Ranch, la famille est devenue
une commune à nouveau,
et sa réputation grandit
autour de Los Angeles.
De nouveaux abonnés ont trouvé leur chemin
à cette idylle champêtre,
avec les membres
des gangs de motards
les satans droits
et les esclaves de Satan
et chiffres
du monde de la musique.
Le Manson
Présence de la famille au Spahn Ranch
était comme un psychédélique
Petite maison dans la prairie.
Je veux dire, c'était juste
un joli retour en arrière.
Ces gars étaient
sur un ancien plateau de tournage.
Ils s'habillaient
en costumes.
C'était
une scène joyeuse.
C'était l'amour gratuit,
médicaments gratuits,
musique, nourriture gratuite
de la benne
et des gens célèbres
tombaient, ouais.
Denis Wilson était là.
Il a pris les filles
sur un camion benne à ordures.
C'est dit Jim Morrison
est allé là-bas.
Chaque fois que Terry et moi nous sommes présentés
ou Dennis et moi sommes arrivés
au ranch,
il serait certainement
avoir tout mis en place.
Quand nous y étions,
tout le monde était en alerte
et nous étions censés
se divertir.
J'ai dit: "Terry, nous devrions...
cela devrait être filmé.
"Nous devrions filmer cette chose.
C'est l'histoire.
"C'est vraiment inhabituel."
Je veux dire, vous avez les filles.
Vous avez les chevaux.
Vous avez des cow-boys.
Vous avez les hippies.
Vous avez le gang de motards
et tu as
ce grand ranch de cinéma.
Tu ne pouvais pas
inventer ce genre de choses.
J'ai pensé, "Terry,
nous devrions filmer ça."
Et tandis que
la famille s'acclimatait
à cette nouvelle vie rurale,
Dennis Wilson a annoncé
que les Beach Boys avaient accepté
enregistrer une des chansons
que lui et Manson
avait travaillé sur
plus tôt dans l'été.
Ce morceau, "Cease to Exist",
parfaitement capturé
le chef de la secte
perspective spirituelle.
♪ Cesse d'exister
♪ Juste, viens et dis que tu m'aimes
♪ Abandonne, ton monde
♪ Allez tu peux être
♪ Je suis ton genre...
C'était
plus la composition de Charlie
que celui de Denis.
Charlie viendrait vraiment
d'un endroit différent.
Charlie était
beaucoup plus philosophique,
type de
une philosophie orientale,
et Dennis était fasciné
avec cela dans une certaine mesure.
Il pouvait sentir
qu'il y avait quelque chose là-bas
mais ne savait pas ce que c'était.
Alors il est allé de pair avec ça.
Il aimait ça.
C'était quelque chose de nouveau.
Les Beach Boys n'écrivaient pas
sur ce genre de choses non plus.
Ils faisaient encore
chansons de surf
et "Bonnes Vibrations"
et ainsi de suite qui était tout cool.
Mais c'était un grand départ
et c'était beaucoup
les années 60, tu sais.
C'était nouveau.
Mais au fur et à mesure que le groupe s'en allait
dans le home studio de Brian Wilson
pour enregistrer la piste
en septembre 1968,
ils ont façonné la chanson
dans leur propre création,
et son nom a été modifié
à "N'apprenez jamais à ne pas aimer".
Stéphane Desper,
l'ingénieur maison du groupe,
supervisait les séances.
Nous étions tous conscients
que Dennis avait un ami
nommé Charles Manson
et eux deux
étaient tous deux musiciens.
Et comme le font les musiciens,
ils comparent leurs notes.
Ils écrivent des choses ensemble.
C'était une collaboration
et Charles et Denis
y avaient travaillé ensemble.
C'était peut-être
l'idée initiale
peut-être Charles',
mais il l'avait donné à Dennis
et été indemnisé pour cela.
Et... Les Beach Boys
le prenaient
et l'embellir comme ils le font
et se l'approprier.
♪ ...ooo je t'aime
jolie fille
♪ Ma vie est à toi,
et tu peux avoir mon monde
♪ Je suis ton genre, je suis ton genre,
et je vois
♪ Je n'ai jamais eu de cours
j'ai jamais appris
♪ Je sais que je ne pourrais jamais apprendre
ne pas t'aimer...
Denis,
qui connaissait son chemin dans un studio
et connaissait son chemin
autour des arrangements vocaux,
pris cette idée
et l'a élargi
dans quelque chose qui était...
plus appétissant,
c'était pop.
Et encore pour les Beach Boys,
ça poussait
leur son vers l'avant.
♪ Entrez maintenant plus près
♪ Rapprochez-vous
approchez-vous ahhhh...
Je pense que c'est une très bonne chanson.
je pense que c'est mieux en fait
qu'il obtient le crédit pour.
Les harmonies sont juste
magnifique sur cette chanson.
Je pense que la collaboration
entre Dennis et Manson
a vraiment montré du potentiel
avec ce "Ne jamais apprendre
Chanson de ne pas aimer".
Je pense que cela fonctionne définitivement.
Je pense que c'est une victoire
pour les Beach Boys.
Et je pense qu'un album
plein de ce genre de son
aurait été incroyable
pour eux à l'époque.
Pourtant, ce ne devait pas être le cas.
Alors que l'enregistrement devrait avoir
à condition que la famille
avec un nouvel espoir,
de retour au Spahn Ranch
l'ambiance changeait,
et la commune de Manson
perdait sa concentration.
Les choses étaient
devient un peu plus rude,
tout le monde je pense
commencé à s'éloigner,
car de plus en plus
nous entendions des histoires
que les esclaves de Satan
traînaient maintenant là-bas.
La photo était...
la partie florale s'en allait.
Ce n'était pas des fleurs
et les perles plus.
C'était des motos
et essence
et les drogues et les personnes les plus dures
venant du centre-ville de LA
que personne ne savait.
Et l'hiver arrivait.
C'était un peu comme l'été
était... la saison se terminait.
Il faisait plus sombre plus tôt
et ainsi de suite.
Et cela reflétait
une obscurité
qui s'était répandu
dans toute la contre-culture
courant 1968.
L'été de l'amour
n'était plus qu'un lointain souvenir,
la guerre du Vietnam
continué à s'intensifier,
et après les assassinats
du premier Martin Luther King
puis Robert Kennedy,
la foi de la jeune génération
dans le changement politique conventionnel
a été écrasé.
À travers le pays,
la contre-culture
a pris les armes
et préparé
pour se battre avec les autorités,
avec de violents affrontements
éclater dans plusieurs villes.
En même temps,
le paisible
mouvement des droits civiques
se transformait aussi,
et alors que les émeutes éclataient
après l'assassinat de King,
Black Power
est devenu un nouveau slogan
pour de nombreux groupes
chercher à affronter
leurs oppresseurs blancs.
Et tous ces courants
alimenté directement
dans l'esprit de Charles Manson.
Maintenant ses sermons modifiés,
et sa vision spirituelle
d'une société communale
a été remplacé par des prédictions
d'une apocalypse à venir -
un soulèvement violent
dans lequel les Afro-Américains
renverserait
la commande existante.
Les idées
que Manson jouait
avec, guerre raciale, révolution,
le sentiment que tout
s'effondrait.
Je veux dire, c'étaient
idées communément admises.
Même au moment où Martin
Luther King a été assassiné,
il avait été débordé
à sa gauche
par plus militant
personnalités politiques noires.
Alors une fois qu'il était
abattu et tué,
il y avait le message de
tu vois où
la non-violence vous gagne ?
L'idée que la structure
a été agressé,
couple que
avec le compliqué,
pour le moins,
histoire raciale
des États-Unis,
le sentiment que ces forces
étaient potentiellement en charge
d'un rachat -
oui encore ça
était quelque chose
c'était très dans l'air du temps.
Mais Manson
pris ces croyances communes
et les a déformés
dans une vision très singulière.
En septembre, conscient que
son contrôle sur ses partisans
glissait à
le Spahn Ranch surpeuplé,
il a repéré un nouvel emplacement
pour leur commune
profondément dans le coeur
de la Vallée de la Mort.
200 milles au nord de Los Angeles,
Ranch de Barker
offert un isolement total,
et il a nourri ça
dans sa prédiction
de la révolution à venir.
Quand la population noire
s'est levé
renverser
les autorités blanches,
leur commune serait cachée
dans cette retraite reculée du désert,
et quand la poussière est retombée
ils émergeraient pour régner
sur un nouveau monde courageux.
Les temps étaient différents.
Ce n'était pas pareil
aimer... communier
sorte d'illumination
chose plus.
Il y avait un ordre du jour.
Il avait toujours été
genre de parrainage
et pose
quelques travaux au sol
pour cette guerre raciale.
Je pense qu'il croyait vraiment
que cela allait arriver
et donc il a toujours été
sorte de nous préparer.
Mais tout l'élan
était de gagner de l'argent...
... pour obtenir des buggies des dunes
et des couteaux et des fusils ou quoi que ce soit
et se cacher dans le désert
jusqu'à ce que cette histoire de guerre soit terminée.
Et tout comme la musique
semblait avoir reculé
en arrière-plan
de la Famille
existence quotidienne,
un disque est sorti
a secoué Manson jusqu'au plus profond de lui-même.
Ayant envoyé plusieurs
ses partisans à Death Valley
pour préparer leur nouveau
hébergement dans le désert,
lui et le reste
membres de la famille
a emménagé dans une maison
sur la rue Gresham
dans la partie nord
de Los Angeles.
C'est ici qu'il a d'abord
entendu le nouvel album des Beatles,
communément connue
comme l'album blanc.
À travers plusieurs de ses chansons,
en quelque sorte les Beatles
envoyaient un message
directement à Manson lui-même,
confirmant ses prophéties
d'une violente guerre raciale.
Quand je suis revenu
du désert
à la rue Gresham
et il y avait tout ça
énergie frénétique et beaucoup d'elle
avait à voir avec le fait
que Charlie ressentait
Les Beatles,
à travers l'Album Blanc,
lui disaient
que cette guerre raciale noir/blanc
était pêle-mêle.
ça tombe vite,
Vous savez,
et il le jouerait
en arrière.
Il était obsédé
et je me souviens
il m'a fait rester et écouter
et pisser mon pantalon
sur le tapis
parce qu'il ne me laisserait pas
partir pour aller aux toilettes.
"Non, tu dois rester ici.
Je veux que tu entendes ça."
♪ As-tu vu
les petits cochons
♪ Ramper dans la saleté
♪ Et pour tous les petits cochons
La vie empire...
"Piggies" était l'un
du premier dont il a parlé,
écrit par George Harrison.
Et George a dit plus tard
sa mère a en fait suggéré
quelques paroles
que Charlie pensait
Les Beatles proclamaient
sur la façon dont il y avait
certaines personnes
qui devait être puni.
Ce dont ils ont besoin
est un putain de bon coup.
♪ Dans leurs yeux
il manque quelque chose
♪ Ce dont ils ont besoin
une sacrée bonne claque...
Harrison faisait juste une fouille
dans les classes supérieures etc, etc.
Mais bien sûr Manson l'a vu
comme un appel aux armes.
Ce dont ils ont besoin
est un putain de bon coup.
"Piggies" est certainement
une chanson violente
et le mot "cochon"
jouerait un rôle important
dans la famille Manson
infamie plus tard.
♪ Merle chantant
dans la mort de la nuit
♪ Prends ces ailes brisées
et apprendre à voler
♪ Toute ta vie
♪ Tu n'attendais que
pour que ce moment se présente...
La chanson "Blackbird",
Charlie a conduit ses partisans
croire
était particulièrement significatif.
Que bien que les noirs
à la vue de Charlie
étaient très inférieurs,
ils avaient été réduits en esclavage,
ils avaient été maltraités
depuis si longtemps
et maintenant les Beatles disaient
ils allaient se soulever.
Tu n'attendais que
pour que votre moment se lève.
Et puis il y a
le vrai crochet. Helter Skelter.
En Grande-Bretagne, les gens se rendraient compte
Paul McCartney parle de
un manège de parc d'attractions.
Mais en Amérique, personne ne savait
quel pêle-mêle était,
et Charlie en a profité
de ça.
♪ Quand j'arrive au fond
♪ Je remonte au sommet
du toboggan
♪ Où je m'arrête et je tourne
et je vais faire un tour
♪ Jusqu'à ce que j'arrive au fond
et je te revois...
Quand tu arrives au fond
vous remontez au sommet -
c'est les noirs.
Ils sont en bas,
ils vont aller au sommet.
Helter Skelter est le nom
Les Beatles ont donné
à la guerre des races
ça vient.
♪ Pêle-mêle, pêle-mêle
Au bord du gouffre...
Charlie a acheté ça
parce que ça vient
des Beatles.
Cela correspondait aux prédictions de Charlie.
Que cela arrivait,
cette guerre, cette guerre noir/blanc
arrivait.
La vie à l'intérieur
la Famille a radicalement changé
dans les premiers mois de 1969.
Pour leur exode vers le désert,
ils auraient besoin de véhicules,
essence et armement,
et Manson est revenu
à ses voies criminelles
pour financer ces nouvelles activités.
Mais le rêve musical
était loin d'être terminé.
En mars,
Dennis Wilson est réapparu
avec l'offre
d'une session de démonstration pour Manson.
Les résultats seraient présentés
aux Beach Boys eux-mêmes
pour voir s'ils le feraient
le signer sur leur nouveau label,
Dossiers Frère.
L'enregistrement aurait lieu
au home studio de Brian Wilson,
avec l'ingénieur du groupe
Stephen Despers
en charge de la séance.
Quelqu'un
frappé à la porte du studio
et dit que votre talent est ici.
Alors je l'ai rencontré
à la porte avant.
C'était Charles
et il avait avec lui cinq filles.
Il a sorti sa guitare
et il avait du talent.
Je pouvais voir pourquoi Dennis
voulait faire une démo avec lui
et le considère comme un talent
ils signaient et produisaient.
C'était la partie productrice
ça m'a dérangé.
Une fois qu'il a obtenu
devant le micro
et dans
l'environnement d'enregistrement
il n'était pas comme les autres.
Tout était très étranger
à lui
et il était énervé
par le tout.
Et je n'étais tout simplement pas
se sentir à l'aise
d'être autour de lui.
Charlie avait
sa façon de faire les choses.
Il savait mieux.
Être une rock star,
une rock star célèbre
n'était pas sa priorité absolue,
parce que si c'était
sa plus haute priorité,
oh, pour rencontrer les Beach Boys,
pour enregistrer dans leur studio...
Ouais, qu'est-ce que tu veux
veux que je porte,
comment aimeriez-vous mes cheveux,
Vous savez. Droite?
Après la première chanson,
il est venu
dans la salle de contrôle
et nous avons fait une lecture.
Au cours de la lecture
il a sorti
un cran d'arrêt de 6 pouces
et a commencé à nettoyer
ses ongles. Je lui ai dit,
"Charlie, prends le couteau
hors de l'atelier."
La raison en était
parce que c'était la maison de Brian
et il a de la famille là-bas,
il a des petites filles à l'étage.
je ne sais pas quoi
ce gars est... tu sais.
Il a appelé une des filles
et ils ont pris le couteau
vers la voiture,
et puis j'ai dû sortir
et le ramener
dans le studio,
assurez-vous qu'ils ne l'étaient pas
errant autour de la maison
et tout ça.
Mais il aimait ce qu'il avait fait,
il en était satisfait.
Je suppose qu'il était là
environ trois ou quatre heures
assez bien dans la soirée.
Malgré la satisfaction de Manson
avec ses performances,
il avait échoué
pour convaincre Stephen Desper,
à qui était le travail
rendre compte au groupe
et leur gestion.
J'ai apporté les cassettes au bureau.
Ils m'ont demandé comment ça s'était passé
et j'ai dit,
"Il ne prendra pas de direction,
« et je ne pense pas
il va être productible.
"Mais ses chansons
sont assez bons.
"J'aime les paroles"
et ainsi de suite.
Et, vous savez, écoutez.
Dossiers de frère
n'étaient pas intéressés,
et bien que cette nouvelle n'ait jamais alimenté
directement à Charles Manson,
il a supposé
de leur silence
qu'il n'allait pas
faire partie de leur liste.
Ses attentions se tournèrent alors
à Terry Melcher, le producteur,
avec qui il avait socialisé
depuis l'année précédente
et qui était encore peu fréquent
visiteur de Spahn Ranch.
Charlie comprend,
quand Dennis Wilson
Je ne peux pas lui obtenir un contrat d'enregistrement,
que, "Attendez une minute,
J'ai mal calculé."
Les artistes ne sont pas assez haut
sur la chaîne alimentaire eux-mêmes.
Et maintenant il a
une autre cible en tête.
Cette cible est Terry Melcher.
Tu dois t'en rappeler
que Manson a essayé
pour obtenir Melcher
pour l'écouter
depuis plus d'un an.
Et il se fait rebuter
et il se fait rebuter.
Et finalement Melcher a dit,
"Je sortirai
au Spahn Ranch.
"Je vais t'écouter."
Il a dit: "Réglez l'heure
et la date."
Il a soulevé les espoirs de tout le monde
que nous allions
faire un disque,
et gagner un peu d'argent.
Et vraiment à ce point
l'argent devait partir
pour le gaz et les véhicules
et de la nourriture et des fournitures...
pour le désert.
Terry Melcher
a d'autres choses
passe dans sa vie.
La succession de sa mère
Il y a des problèmes en cours,
et il ne part pas.
Pour lui, "Eh bien, et alors,
"Je vais juste appeler le gars
à un moment donné et dire,
"'Hey désolé
Je n'ai pas pu le faire la dernière fois.'"
Pour Manson ce n'est pas
juste une trahison personnelle...
mais cela menace son emprise
ses partisans et il est furieux.
Et il part à la recherche
Terry Melcher.
Le premier endroit où il va chercher
pour Terry Melcher
c'est là qu'il a connu Terry Melcher
vécu, Cielo Drive,
mais Melcher a déménagé.
Lui et Candice Bergen
sont allés dans un endroit
sur la plage,
une propriété que Doris Day possédait.
Et maintenant
il y a de nouveaux locataires.
Roman Polansky
et Sharon Tate.
Polanski et Tate
étaient l'un des LA
les couples les plus glamour,
représentant
d'un nouvel Hollywood
qui embrassait
la contre-culture.
Les films européens de Polanski
plus tôt dans la décennie
lui avait apporté
à l'attention internationale,
et c'était en travaillant
sur le dernier d'entre eux,
"Les tueurs de vampires intrépides",
qu'il a jeté et est tombé amoureux
avec Sharon Tate,
l'actrice principale.
Amis proches de Terry Melcher
et Candice Bergen,
le couple avait déménagé
dans la maison sur Cielo Drive
en mars 1969.
C'était à la fin de ce mois
que Charles Manson
est venu en marchant
furieusement dans l'allée
à la recherche de Melcher.
Sharon Tate
a un photographe,
son photographe personnel
qui se trouve être là-bas.
Et le gars voit
prendre d'assaut le lecteur
ce petit mec à l'air débraillé
l'air un peu furieux,
"Que veux-tu?"
Et pour Terry Melcher,
c'est la résidence Polanski.
Vous êtes au mauvais endroit.
Le propriétaire habite à l'arrière.
Manson dit : "Je vais le voir."
"N'allez pas sur la pelouse,
éloignez-vous de la maison principale."
Il fait irruption et le gars
qui possède la propriété dit,
"Oh, il a déménagé. Je ne veux pas
tu reviens
"sans dire aux gens
tu es en route."
Manson s'en va,
et alors qu'il s'en va
une belle femme sort
de la maison principale
et il la regarde
pour une minute,
puis il s'en va.
Charlie Manson et Sharon Tate
se sont regardés
dans les yeux très brièvement.
Quand il fut enfin
capable de localiser Terry Melcher,
Manson a réorganisé leur rencontre,
et le 6 juin 1969,
le producteur a voyagé
au Spahn Ranch
regarder les 34 ans
ex-détenu
effectuer un ensemble élaboré.
Cela prendrait des semaines
avant que Manson ne puisse
tirer une réponse de Melcher
quant à savoir si
il le recommanderait
à Columbia Records.
Et ce n'était pas la réponse
qu'il espérait...
Terry a finalement dit à Charlie.
Il a dit : "Hé Charlie,
J'apprécie vraiment votre musique.
"C'est vraiment bien,
mais ce n'est tout simplement pas ma tasse de thé.
"Je ne sais pas ce que je ferais
avec toi en studio."
Charlie avait le cœur brisé.
Il a été écrasé par ça.
Charlie était
j'y compte vraiment
et je pense qu'il avait
ses espoirs levés...
Je pense qu'ils l'ont encouragé.
Ils auraient dû être
un peu plus à l'avance,
au début.
Mais peut-être ont-ils vu
quelque chose en lui.
Et je pense que Dennis l'a fait.
C'était une côtelette de karaté
jusqu'au cou pour lui,
parce que je sais
il pensait vraiment que
il l'avait vraiment là-dedans.
Terry était producteur de disques.
C'est quoi
un artiste d'enregistrement a besoin
et un producteur de disques
avec un palmarès
et une carte blanche
dans un grand studio.
Ouais, c'est tout,
si vous êtes Charlie à ce moment-là.
Donc, oui, c'était écrasant.
Je suis sûr que
était écrasant pour Charlie.
Les événements
qui suivit tragiquement
ont été alimentés par ce rejet
et le désespoir
qui s'installait à travers
les activités chaotiques de la famille.
Et comme cela avait été le cas
dans sa jeunesse,
Manson a prouvé
un criminel sans espoir.
A ce même moment
Charlie a prévenu
à propos de Helter Skelter
et nous devons revenir
au désert.
Personne ici ne touche d'argent.
Pour acheter les fournitures dont ils ont besoin
est en faisant des affaires de drogue.
Et parmi les gens
il fait affaire avec
il y a un professeur de musique
nommé Gary Hinman qu'il connaît.
Et il y a un grand noir
connu sous le nom de Lotsappappa,
et les réclamations de Lotsappappa
être une panthère noire.
Et Hinman parle
d'aller en Europe.
Cela signifie donc que Hinman
a obtenu de l'argent.
Avec Lotsappappa,
le trafic de drogue tourne mal,
Charlie avec
un pistolet Buntline Special 22
qu'il a apporté, lui tire dessus
et pense qu'il l'a tué.
Parce qu'il a tué Lotsappappa,
devient soudainement convaincu
que les Black Panthers
vont venir
après Manson et la famille.
Et Charly
peut avoir parlé
une apocalypse raciale
et tout le reste
et exagérait,
mais Charlie avait une peur bleue
des Black Panthers.
Ce désastreux
trafic de drogue en juillet 1969,
était suivi
par un événement encore pire
à la fin du mois.
La cohorte occasionnelle de la famille
Bobby Beausoleil
dirigeait un trafic de drogue
impliquant son Topanga
Fournisseur Canyon,
le musicien Gary Hinman,
et le gang de motards
Les satans hétéros
qui étaient des invités fréquents
au Spahn Ranch.
Quand les motards accusaient
Beausoleil de les arnaquer
avec un produit de qualité inférieure,
lui et trois membres
de la famille
visité Hinman
pour récupérer leur argent.
Mais une bagarre s'ensuivit,
l'événement a dégénéré
hors de contrôle
et après deux jours
dans son appartement,
Bobby Beausoleil
assassiné Hinman,
griffonner des messages
dans le sang du musicien
à travers les murs de l'appartement.
Il a fallu la police
seulement deux semaines
pour appréhender le meurtrier.
La mort de Gary Hinman,
qui impliquait plusieurs membres
de la famille Manson
et principalement
Bobby Beausoleil,
qui n'était pas une carte portant
membre de la famille Manson
mais était certainement étroitement lié
De plusieurs façons,
à ce point
c'est aussi le trafic de drogue
avec la famille Manson.
En fin de compte et si qui nous sommes
croire apparemment,
mais prétendument Manson
avait dit à Beausoleil,
"Vous savez ce qu'il faut faire",
qui a conduit à la mort de Hinman.
Beausoleil
tourne hors de contrôle
est récupéré très bientôt
avec du sang partout sur lui.
Cela a ramené au meurtre
et Beausoleil est arrêté.
La prison de Manson nous
dirait,
"Bon tu sais,
ça va me revenir".
Il n'aurait peut-être pas dit
"Vous savez ce qu'il faut faire,"
mais certainement les brins
courent tous en arrière.
L'affaire a été menée
du Ranch de Spahn,
peut-être facilité par Manson.
C'était certainement
tout va le ramener à lui.
Peur que
il serait rattrapé
dans l'affaire Beausoleil,
Manson a déclaré
que le temps
car 'Helter Skelter' était venu,
et envoya quatre de ses partisans
dans la nuit de Los Angeles
commettre un meurtre imitateur,
dirigé par Tex Watson, 24 ans.
Il y avait deux objectifs.
Premièrement, que de nouveaux crimes
dirigerait la police
supposer que Beausoleil
était innocent
et que le tueur
était toujours en liberté,
et deuxièmement, que la police
ciblerait les Afro-Américains
pour les meurtres et donc
déclencher la guerre raciale.
Et regardant
pour des cibles de haut niveau,
Manson a envoyé son groupe de chasse
à l'ancienne résidence de Terry Melcher
sur Cielo Drive.
C'était l'emplacement.
Il avait besoin de tuer
des personnes célèbres
et essayer de faire ressembler
les Panthers l'avaient fait
pour évacuer la chaleur
Bobby Beausoleil.
L'endroit qu'il
était le plus familier avec
où des gens riches et célèbres
devait vivre était Cielo.
Si quelqu'un vivait
où Melcher avait vécu,
c'était quelqu'un d'important.
La deuxième chose critique
pourquoi cet endroit a été choisi
Tex Watson en plus de Charlie
avait été à la maison de Cielo
et savait théoriquement comment
pour s'y rendre depuis Spahn Ranch.
C'est pourquoi ils ont choisi
cette maison.
Les meurtres qui
survenu le 8 août 1969,
étaient parmi les plus
crimes brutaux de l'époque,
Sharon Tate
et ses trois invités
tué sans aucun remords.
Et la nuit suivante,
la tuerie continue,
avec un couple bourgeois aisé
Romarin et Leno LaBianca
souffrant de la même façon
mort violente.
Une autre nuit sauvage de meurtre
mais curieusement,
sur le plan musical,
c'est la nuit
quand ils ont décidé
barbouiller "Mort aux cochons".
La nuit avant qu'ils mettent "cochon"
encore à la porte
faisant référence aux Beatles.
Le motif clé cette nuit-là
était "Helter Skelter"
écrit sur la porte du frigo.
J'ai mes propres sentiments
c'est pourquoi les tueries
arrêté à ce moment-là,
certainement ceux
sorte de meurtres,
est-ce que quand ils sont retournés à
Le ranch de Spahn
et Manson les débrieferait
de ce qui s'était passé.
Quand il a entendu
Patricia Krenwinkel
avait écrit "Helter Skelter"
en sang sur la porte du frigo,
il a paniqué.
Tout le monde était au courant
"Helter Skelter" de Manson
théories, obsessions.
Il y avait même une discothèque
au Ranch de Spahn
appelé le Helter Skelter.
Donc je pense que c'est
quand Manson a complètement effrayé
et c'est alors que le déménagement
à Barker Ranch s'est produite.
Mais Manson
était encore à court d'argent.
Ne plus s'inquiéter
sur ses relations
dans l'industrie de la musique,
il a décidé
il devait encore de l'argent
pour l'enregistrement des Beach Boys
de "cesser d'exister",
dont les paroles Dennis avaient changé
sans même
demander sa permission.
Il partit à travers LA
chasser le batteur,
et l'a finalement trouvé
avec Gregg Jakobson
et les Beach Boys
photographe Ed Roach.
C'était juste après
le festival de Woodstock a commencé
donc je sais que c'était comme
une semaine ou deux
après l'épisode Cielo Drive
et... il, il est entré
et il vient de sauter
dans la pièce
et il ressemblait à
il a regardé dans les journaux
où ses cheveux étaient comme
debout et il a sauté dedans
et il a dit: "Je viens d'arriver
de la lune".
Je suis allé, "Putain de merde, c'est
ce gars-là Charlie."
Charlie a dit, "J'ai besoin de parler
avec toi,"
et il l'emmena dehors.
Dennis est revenu,
est entré, a attrapé la guitare
et est sorti et est revenu
sans la guitare
et il a dit: "Je devais lui donner
tout mon argent et la guitare
"ou il a dit qu'il allait
kidnapper mon fils le matin
"et le tuer."
C'était...
c'était au-dessus de la chanson.
C'était la fin
de la relation
et la fin de Manson
Connexions
à la scène musicale de LA.
La semaine suivante,
lui et ses partisans ont sauté
dans leurs buggies des dunes
et se mit en route,
direction le désert.
Et tandis que Los Angeles
la police a lutté
faire des progrès
dans les enquêtes
de la Tate
ou les meurtres de LaBianca,
dans la vallée de la mort
cette commune nouvellement arrivée
a rapidement suscité l'intérêt
de la police locale.
En octobre, à travers deux raids,
la police a arrêté
la famille Manson
ayant découvert leur flotte
de buggies des dunes volés.
Charles Manson
et certains des meurtriers
ont été placés en garde à vue,
sur des accusations beaucoup moins graves,
et en attendant
dans un centre de détention,
Membre de la famille Susan Atkins,
un participant
dans les deux invasions de domicile,
a commencé à se vanter
les meurtres à un codétenu.
C'était le plomb
l'enquête nécessaire.
Connecter les différents brins
de l'histoire
et interrogeant Manson
suiveurs,
le LAPD
et le procureur de la République
furent bientôt confiants
ils avaient trouvé les meurtriers.
Ils ont convoqué une conférence de presse
le 1er décembre 1969,
annoncer
que l'affaire était résolue.
Charles Manson et sa famille
est devenu instantanément tristement célèbre.
Mon personnel
la réaction a été l'incrédulité au début
parce qu'il n'avait pas l'air si mauvais.
Il était bizarre mais je ne l'ai pas fait
pense qu'il en était capable.
Je ne pensais pas que ces filles
là-bas dans le studio
étaient capables de poignarder les gens.
Quand je lis
à ce sujet, j'étais nerveux. Quoi?
J'étais sous le choc, tu sais.
Je n'y croyais pas au début.
Les filles... je ne pouvais pas croire
comment ils avaient changé.
Je veux dire, ils sont sortis là-bas
et des gens massacrés.
Ils ne sont pas,
«Regarde-toi, petite fille.
"Laisse tomber. Donne
tout ton amour."
Ils sont sortis là-bas
et vicieusement tué des gens.
j'étais à la maison
et quelqu'un m'a appelé,
"as-tu entendu
ce qui s'est passé?"
Quand on m'a dit ça,
J'ai pensé une seconde
et j'ai dit: "C'est réel.
"C'est vraiment arrivé."
Je n'étais pas surpris.
Tout avait un sens pour moi.
C'était allé si loin
hors de l'équilibre,
si loin hors de contrôle.
Dans le monde de la musique lui-même
la panique s'est rapidement propagée.
Bien que Manson et
les meurtriers étaient derrière les barreaux,
de nombreux membres de la famille élargie
étaient encore libres.
Convaincu qu'il était la véritable cible
de l'attaque de Cielo Drive,
Terry Melcher
en particulier était anxieux,
tandis que ceux
qui avait été impliqué
avec Manson de quelque manière que ce soit
cherché à protéger
leurs réputations
et se sont éloignés
de l'histoire.
Terry est allé
et acheté un fusil anti-émeute,
un fusil de chasse de calibre 12
avec un canon court scié.
Il contient comme six coquillages.
Il l'a littéralement gardé
par sa porte d'entrée.
Ils étaient très inquiets.
Dennis un peu moins mais
Dennis en rirait plus
mais Terry était ouais...
Oh non, Terry a pris ça au sérieux.
Il ne savait pas quoi
ces gens étaient capables de
et il n'allait pas
tente ta chance.
j'ai reçu un appel
de la direction de Beach Boy.
Ils m'ont dit qu'ils étaient
va prendre les bandes
et mettez-les en lieu sûr.
Ils voulaient s'assurer
il n'y avait pas d'exemplaires
ou quelque chose comme ça.
Dennis était parti
vers une zone non divulguée.
Personne ne savait vraiment
où il était
mais il y avait un sens
que Dennis a été menacé.
ça ne le satisfaisait pas
du tout que Charlie était en prison.
Qu'il n'était pas
plus en danger.
L'ensemble de Dennis
la personnalité a changé.
Il n'était pas du tout
la même personne.
Il y avait une paranoïa
à propos de lui.
La peur de... tu sais,
à quel point il était proche de tout cela...
Et comme le District
Avocat chargé de l'affaire,
Vincent Bugliosi,
commencé à chercher des témoins
faire appel pendant le procès,
il a trouvé des proches de Manson
dans le monde du divertissement
ne voulaient pas ternir leur
réputation en prenant position.
Denis n'était pas
va coopérer avec Bugliosi
et Terry non plus.
Je crois que Terry a fait
un accord avec Bugliosi.
Qu'est-ce que c'était, je ne sais pas.
Bugliosi recherché
d'amener Dennis au tribunal,
Je veux dire, un Beach Boy.
Il voulait apporter
Candice Bergen au tribunal,
La petite amie de Terry.
Donc, je veux dire, ça ne pouvait pas arriver
dans le monde de Terry.
Il a tout fait pour...
en rester le plus loin possible
et Dennis a fait la même chose.
D'accord, j'y étais.
Je te le dirai...
Alors j'ai coopéré.
je ne disais pas
des mensonges
et je n'ai pas vu
quelque chose de criminel arrive
donc je n'ai pas... je ne disais pas,
"Oui, j'ai vu le pistolet
ou quelque chose."
J'ai juste dit la vérité.
Manson, quant à lui,
essayait de garder le contrôle
de ses partisans
de l'Intérieur,
et avait hâte
générer des revenus
cela l'aiderait à le faire.
Maintenant qu'il était sur le front
pages à travers le monde,
il a décidé que c'était le parfait
le temps de sortir un disque,
le rêve de la rock star
refuser de mourir.
Manson a senti les bandes
de la maison de Brian Wilson
étaient une musique brillante.
Si cela devait être
sa seule chance
pour obtenir une déclaration musicale
dehors, il aimait cette idée.
Aussi, il avait, des frais juridiques
pas seulement pour lui-même
mais pour les femmes du procès.
Il désespérément
devait s'assurer
qu'ils allaient
lui rester fidèle.
Leurs avocats voulaient tous
séparer leurs affaires
de Manson
afin qu'ils puissent prétendre que,
"Ah, les femmes
ont été trompés par cet homme".
Charlie devait garder
tout le monde heureux.
Charlie devait gagner de l'argent
et quelle meilleure façon de le faire,
il pensait,
que de finalement libérer
ce grand album de lui
que simultanément
ferait de lui une rock star
et en même
qui couvre tous les frais juridiques.
Manson s'est enrôlé
Lynette Fromme,
connu au sein de la Famille
comme "Squeaky",
pour que cela se produise.
Et même si elle a découvert
que les enregistrements
de l'atelier de Brian Wilson
étaient sous clé,
elle a convaincu Gregg Jakobson
libérer les bandes d'une session
il avait arrangé
aux studios Sound City
au milieu de 1968.
Elle a alors appelé
Phil Kaufman pour l'aider
à la sortie du disque,
et Kaufmann,
qui croyait à cette époque
Manson doit être innocent,
accepté d'aider.
Lynette... Squeaky m'a contacté,
"Nous devons obtenir
La musique de Charlie est sortie",
Parce que d'une manière ou d'une autre, il pensait
que l'album serait...
les gens entendraient la musique
et comprendrait
que ce qu'il faisait
était précieux.
Elle a la bande,
et je l'ai emmené en studio,
nous l'avons nettoyé
et nous avons fait le mixage.
J'ai des gens
verser de l'argent
pour l'éteindre
et nous avons fait 300 exemplaires.
C'était la couverture du magazine "Life"
où nous avons laissé tomber le 'f'
hors de la "vie"
et c'est devenu le 'mensonge'.
C'est un mensonge, il est innocent.
Comment peux-tu écouter
à sa musique,
comment pouvez-vous l'accuser
pour une telle chose.
♪ Clang bang clang
Est allé la grande porte de fer
♪ Ils m'ont mis dans une cellule
Avec un sol en béton
♪ Neuf autres hommes
dans cette cellule avec moi
♪ Moanin 'leur destin,
avec le destin
♪ Clang bang clang...
C'est...
un des albums originaux.
Vous pouvez dire que c'est original
par l'étiquette jaune.
Tout le reste est un bootleg.
Alors il m'a demandé de prendre
l'album et je l'ai fait.
Et à ce jour
J'ai regretté mon association,
mais tu ne peux pas te divorcer
du passé.
L'enregistrement,
dès sa sortie,
n'a reçu aucun des succès
que Manson a estimé qu'il méritait,
et même son infamie
n'a réussi à déplacer aucune copie.
La carrière de Manson
en tant que musicien
Je pense que c'était peu
conséquence pour les personnes
regarder les gros titres
d'à ce moment-là.
Je pense qu'ils l'ont vu plus
en tant que chef de secte
qu'un musicien,
et quand ils ont entendu la musique,
c'est difficile d'épouser ça
au carnage qui s'est passé
et l'horreur.
Donc une curiosité au mieux,
extrêmement désagréable,
en fait ce qu'il y a de plus
les gens y ont pensé.
Pas de maison de disques
le toucherait de n'importe quelle note
et ça n'allait pas
pour obtenir n'importe quel morceau de radio.
C'est juste un autre exemple
de l'innocence de Manson
accident vasculaire cérébral
qu'il avait imaginé que
n'importe qui voudrait l'acheter.
Alors que le procès Manson devenait
un cirque médiatique dévorant,
la contre-culture
lui-même lutté
traiter avec ce chef de secte
et ses références hippies.
Comme la croisade contre
les idéaux de ce mouvement
avait été enhardi
d'abord par le californien
Gouverneur Ronald Regan
puis titulaire
Président Richard Nixon,
valeurs américaines conservatrices
s'avéraient plus robustes
que la contre-culture
avait cru autrefois.
Alors que certains essayaient de politiser
les meurtres de Tate-LaBianca
et a imprudemment retenu Manson
en tant que leader révolutionnaire,
le plus simplement reconnu
que ces désespérés,
actes choquants
avait terni à jamais un mouvement
prônant la paix et l'amour.
je ne pense pas
par conception Charles Manson est arrivé
pour détruire le rêve hippie,
mais par Dieu il l'a fait,
et les gens ont dit que
à partir du moment en décembre 1969
que Manson était sur le front
des journaux,
toute personne ressemblant à un hippie
était diabolisé.
Si tu étais,
quelqu'un de droite,
qui détestait tout
que la contre-culture
représentait,
tu n'aurais pas pu scénariser
Charles Manson
et ces meurtres odieux
rien de mieux.
Il a donné le droit
toutes les armes qu'il pourrait utiliser.
Je veux dire, il y avait du sexe, là
il y avait de la drogue, il y avait de la violence.
Les Beatles sont là-dedans.
Vous savez, tout ça. Tout.
Il vient de le remettre à la droite.
La part de l'esprit humain
qui est plus tolérant et ouvert
et confiant et moins craintif
est une
de nos super pouvoirs vraiment.
Mais bien sûr
tu t'installes parfois
et je pense que c'en était une
des vrais chocs de Manson
autant comme
les Hell's Angels d'Altamont,
dans certains cas, nous nous sommes liés d'amitié
avec les mauvaises personnes.
Pour beaucoup qui
s'était lié d'amitié avec Charles Manson,
il resterait permanent
présence dans leur vie.
Alors qu'il devenait un exagéré
méchant dans la culture populaire -
un maniaque fou
et cerveau psychotique -
pour certains dessinés
dans son parcours musical,
c'était un vrai
et figure complexe,
et leur association avec lui
laissé des dommages à vie.
Ayant placé une telle foi
dans l'homme qu'il appelait le magicien,
après la nouvelle choquante
des meurtres ont émergé,
Denis Wilson
a été jeté à la dérive.
L'âme autrefois vitale
des Beach Boys
a été hanté par une amitié
il ne pourra jamais effacer,
et avec le temps il s'est perdu
dans la boisson et la drogue.
Il est mort en 1983,
à seulement 39 ans,
et avait refusé
depuis l'arrestation de Manson
jamais discuter
l'affaire en public.
Il n'en a jamais parlé
et je n'ai pas pensé
c'était à moi d'en parler.
Donc Dennis jamais
parlé de cela.
Je suis sûr qu'il se sentait responsable
dans une certaine mesure.
Il s'y est beaucoup investi,
il était tout mêlé à ça.
Dennis jamais
vraiment parlé des meurtres.
Je veux dire,
il réfléchissait parfois
retour sur ses expériences
avec la famille,
mais jamais... je ne sais pas
combien il en fait...
Vous savez que je veux dire,
il a vraiment évité
tout le massacre
aspect de celui-ci.
Dennis n'a jamais vraiment récupéré
du coup émotionnel
qu'il en a retiré.
Denis était déjà
le mouton noir de la bande
et vous savez,
c'est juste fondamentalement...
Juste au moment où il commençait
sortir de ça
et devenir quelque chose
que les gens prenaient
artistiquement sérieux,
c'est arrivé,
et c'est juste fondamentalement
l'a marqué comme un perdant pour toujours.
Je pense qu'il pensait
de lui-même de cette façon.
Je pense que c'était la bataille
pour que les gens le convainquent
il était plus que cela.
je pense juste que
il l'a suivi tout le long du chemin,
jusqu'au bout.
Je ne pense pas qu'il ait jamais
s'en est remis.